READY. OKAY, SO, THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WILL
NOW COME TO ORDER. WE HAVE TEN
MEASURES ON OUR AGENDA TODAY,
AND I'D LIKE TO MAKE A NOTE THAT
AB 2803 WAS PULLED YESTERDAY AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. AND
ALSO AB 2355 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO WILL BE PRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES. I
DON'T THINK WE QUITE HAVE A
QUORUM, SO WE WILL WAIT UNTIL
HELLO. GOOD MORNING. WE WILL
WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE ONE. SO WE
WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
OKAY, GREAT. AND WE DO HAVE AN
AUTHOR HERE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN. SO WE WOULD BE HAPPY
TO START WITH YOU. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING. WHICH ONES DO WE
START WITH? 50. OKAY, OKAY. TO
START WITH 2050. YES. PERFECT.
OKAY. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS. GOOD MORNING. IN A
STATE WITH STATEWIDE MAILED
BALLOTS, THE ACCURACY OF OUR
VOTER RECORDS IS A PARAMOUNT
IMPORTANCE. THE ELECTRONIC
REGISTRATION INFORMATION CENTER,
KNOWN AS ERIC, IS A POWERFUL
TOOL FOR ELECTIONS OFFICIALS CAN
USE TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
MOST UP TO DATE VOTER ROLLS.
ERIC IS A NONPARTISAN NONPROFIT
GOVERNED BY ITS MEMBER STATES
THAT MUTUALLY AGREE TO SHARE
DATA SUCH AS VOTER REGISTRATION
AND VEHICLE LICENSING DATA IN
ORDER TO KEEP THEIR VOTER ROLLS
UPDATED, AND TO REACH OUT TO
ELIGIBLE BUT UNREGISTERED
CITIZENS. THE SECRETARY OF STATE
ESTIMATES THAT THERE ARE 4.7
MILLION UNREGISTERED ELIGIBLE
VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA THAT IS
GREATER THAN THE POPULATION OF
26 STATES. SO WHEN A VOTER
MOVES, THEY OFTEN REREGISTER TO
VOTE IN THEIR NEW JURISDICTION,
BUT DO NOT NOTIFY THE PRIOR
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIAL THAT
THEY HAVE MOVED. DUE TO THE
HIGHLY MOBILE NATURE OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION, IT IS
LIKELY THAT THERE ARE MILLIONS
OF VOTER REGISTRATION RECORDS
THAT ARE OUT OF DATE DUE TO A
RECENT MOVE. ERIC MEMBERS DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO ANY MEMBERS DATA
OR REPORTS STORED ON ERIC'S
SERVERS, AND STATE VOTER
REGISTRATION SYSTEMS ARE NEVER
CONNECTED TO ERIC. AB 2050
AUTHORIZES THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO JOIN ERIC ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE THE STATE WITH DATA ON
VOTERS WHO HAVE MOVED IN STATE,
OUT OF STATE, OR DIED, AS WELL
AS PROVIDING DATA ON
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TO
VOTE BUT ARE UNREGISTERED. ERIC
IS DESIGNED TO WORK WITHIN THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE NATIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION ACT, UNDER WHICH
STATES CANNOT REMOVE VOTERS FROM
THE ROLLS JUST BECAUSE ERIC
REPORTS THEY HAVE MOVED OUT
BEFORE REMOVING A VOTER, STATES
MUST CONTAIN AT THE VOTER, SEEK
TO CONFIRM CONFIRM ERIC'S
INFORMATION ON, AND LEAVE VOTERS
ON THE ROLLS FOR AT LEAST TWO
FEDERAL GENERAL ELECTION CYCLES,
AS IS CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL
LAW. ADDITIONALLY, AB 2050
SPECIFICALLY PROHIBITS THE
SENDING OF AB60 LICENSE DATA IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT NO ONE IS
NO ONE WHO IS INELIGIBLE TO VOTE
IS INCLUDED IN THE DATA SET.
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO INCREASE
THE ACCESSIBILITY OF OUR VOTER
REGISTRATION SYSTEM HAS BEEN A
GREAT SUCCESS. BECOMING AN ERIC
MEMBER IS A NATURAL STEP IN
CALIFORNIA'S MISSION TO IMPROVE
THE ACCESSIBILITY AND EASE OF
VOTING. AB 2050 IS SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ERIC IS SHANE HAMLIN, WHO IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ERIC, AND
TRICIA WEBER, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
AND ELECTIONS OFFICIALS. Þ IS
TRICIA HERE? THANK YOU. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO COME FORWARD TO THE
TABLE HERE. YES, POPS UP AT THE
BACK. I WAS WAITING. OH, DO YOU
WANT TO? SO OUR LEAD WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. YOU HAVE TWO. YES.
AND THEY'RE EACH GIVEN TWO
MINUTES. SO YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY. ALL RIGHT. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR BLAKE. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS SHANE
HAMLIN. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ERIC, THE ELECTRONIC
REGISTRATION INFORMATION CENTER,
AND I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF AB
2050. AS YOU HEARD, ERIC IS A
500 AND 1C3 NONPROFIT MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION CURRENTLY COMPRISED
OF ELECTION OFFICIALS FROM 24
STATES AND THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA. OUR MISSION IS TO HELP
ELECTION OFFICIALS MAINTAIN MORE
ACCURATE VOTER ROLLS AND
INCREASE ACCESS TO VOTER
REGISTRATION FOR ALL ELIGIBLE
CITIZENS. MAINTAINING ACCURATE
VOTER ROLLS IS A SERIOUS AND
ONGOING CHALLENGE, BECAUSE EVERY
DAY VOTERS MOVE OR DIE AND AS
YOU HEARD, MANY DO NOT REPORT
MOVES TO THEIR ELECTION OFFICIAL
AND FEWER STILL FAMILY MEMBERS
REPORT THE DEATH OF A OF A
FAMILY MEMBER. ERIC HELPS
ELECTION OFFICIALS MITIGATE
THESE CHALLENGES IN A SECURE AND
SAFE MANNER. SINCE 2012, ERIC
HAS IDENTIFIED FOR ITS MEMBERS
NEARLY 42 MILLION INACCURATE OR
OUT OF DATE VOTER RECORDS,
INCLUDING 12.5 MILLION VOTERS
WHO HAD MOVED OUT OF STATE AND
OVER 600,000 DECEASED VOTERS.
AND WE'VE ALSO IDENTIFIED NEARLY
60 MILLION POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE
BUT UNREGISTERED INDIVIDUALS. IF
CALIFORNIA WERE TO JOIN ERIC,
BASED ON THE EXPERIENCE OF OUR
CURRENT MEMBERS, WE ESTIMATE
WE'D IDENTIFY IN ITS FIRST SET
OF REPORTS, NEARLY 2 MILLION OUT
OF DATE VOTER RECORDS, INCLUDING
ABOUT A HALF A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE MOVED OUT
OF THE STATE AND ABOUT 4 MILLION
POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE BUT
UNREGISTERED INDIVIDUALS. ERIC
WOULD BE A SECURE COST EFFECTIVE
RESOURCE FOR THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AND THE STATE'S 58 COUNTY
ELECTION OFFICIALS. ERIC
MEMBERSHIP WOULD IMPROVE THE
ACCURACY OF CALIFORNIA VOTER
ROLLS AND EXPAND ACCESS TO VOTER
REGISTRATION INFORMATION TO
POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE, BUT NOT
YET REGISTERED CALIFORNIANS. I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE A LETTER FROM
MICHAEL MORRIS AT THE CAREY
SCHOOL OF LAW AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF PENNSYLVANIA THAT ADDRESSES
SOME RECENT CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED ABOUT USING ERIC
REPORTS FOR LIST MAINTENANCE. I
THINK IT ADDRESSES ALL THOSE
CONCERNS WELL, AND I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. AND I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF AB 2050. THANK YOU.
AND YOU ALSO HAVE TWO MINUTES.
OKAY. THANK YOU. HI, I'M TRICIA
WEBER. I AM A CO-CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CLERK
AND ELECTION OFFICIALS.
ELECTIONS LEGISLATION COMMITTEE,
AND I AM HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2050. WE SPONSORED
THIS BILL, BECAUSE VOTER ROLL
MAINTENANCE IS ONE OF OUR MAIN
JOBS THAT WE NEED TO DO. AND
ERIC PROVIDES US WAYS TO, TO,
GET DATA IN ORDER TO MAKE OUR
ROLLS STRONGER AND MORE CLEAR
THAT WE ARE SENDING BALLOTS TO
VOTERS WE NEED TO SEND BALLOTS
TO AND THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO REACH OUT TO VOTERS WHO ARE
NOT REGISTERED TO GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REGISTER. I JUST
ACTUALLY YESTERDAY, I RECEIVED
IN THE MAIL A CANCELLATION
NOTICE THAT WAS ON A SHEET OF
PAPER THAT WAS LESS THAN AN INCH
IN IN HEIGHT, THAT HAD FLOATED
AROUND SEVERAL COUNTIES BEFORE
MAKING IT TO ME FROM A PERSON
WHO REGISTERED TO VOTE IN
ANOTHER STATE. AND IT WAS THAT
STATE, THEN HAD TO SEND IT TO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE, WHO
TRIED TO INTERPRET THE
REGISTRATION ADDRESS ON IT, SENT
IT TO ONE COUNTY, WHO SENT IT TO
ANOTHER COUNTY, WHO SENT IT TO
ME, AND TURNS OUT THAT THAT
PERSON ACTUALLY MOVED OVER A
YEAR AGO, WHETHER THEY FILLED IT
OUT JUST RECENTLY OR WHETHER IT
TOOK A YEAR TO GET TO ME, IN
ORDER TO PUT THEM TO CANCEL
THEIR REGISTRATION, I DO NOT
KNOW. BUT ERIC WOULD BE A WAY
FOR US TO GET THAT DATA QUICKER
AND BE ABLE TO INFORM OUR VOTERS
THAT WE RECEIVE NOTIFICATION
THAT THEY MOVED AND WE'D BE ABLE
TO CANCEL THEM OR KEEP THEM
ACTIVE WITH A NEW MAILING
ADDRESS, SO WE ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
WELL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO WE
HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES? OH. I'M SORRY. LET'S
GO TO OTHER SUPPORT FIRST. IF
THERE'S OTHER SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM, PLEASE COME FORWARD AND
STATE YOUR SUPPORT. ETHAN
NAGLER, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
CLERK'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MORNING. I'M ERIC LARA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, DEAN
LOGAN, ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
OKAY. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IN
THE ROOM? NOT SEEING ANY. NOW
WE'LL GO TO OUR LEAD. OPPOSITION
WITNESS OR WITNESSES. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO COME FORWARD TO THE
TABLE. IT'S I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANT TO JUST MOVE OVER IN CASE
THERE'S SOME QUESTIONS. YEAH
PERFECT. THANK YOU. AND YOU HAVE
. AND YOU ALSO HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU, MY NAME IS COLLEEN
BRITTON. I'M WITH THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT. CALIFORNIA
IPCA HAS STRONGLY OPPOSED
MEMBERSHIP IN ERIC SINCE IT WAS
FIRST INTRODUCED IN 2023. OUR
SEVERAL POSITION LETTERS ARE ALL
ON FILE, AND WE HOPE YOU HAVE
READ THEM CAREFULLY BEFORE YOU
VOTE TODAY. SEVERAL AWARENESS OF
THE DEPLORABLE CONDITIONS OF
CALIFORNIA VOTER ROLLS HAS
SPREAD AND IS CLEARLY NOW PUBLIC
KNOWLEDGE. RECENT DATA ANALYSIS
SHOWED THAT THERE ARE OVER 2
MILLION ELIGIBLE OR UNCERTAIN
REGISTRANTS VIOLATIONS WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA VOTER ROLL
DATABASE. VOTER ROLLS. FOLLOWING
THE 2022 ELECTION SHOWED THAT
NEARLY 2 MILLION VOTES WERE CAST
BY INELIGIBLE OR UNCERTAIN
REGISTRANTS. IT'S ABSOLUTELY
TRUE. THE SECRETARY OF STATE
MUST DO SOMETHING TO CORRECT THE
PROBLEM. BUT ERIC IS NOT THE
ANSWER. STATES THAT HAVE
WITHDRAWN FROM ERIC MEMBERSHIP
HAVE REMOVED GREATER NUMBERS OF
INELIGIBLE VOTERS THAN WHEN THEY
WERE ERIC MEMBERS. OHIO IS BUT
ONE EXAMPLE. THE TRUTH IS THAT
ERIC'S REQUIREMENTS AND
PROCEDURES, MORE OFTEN THAN NOT,
EXACTLY EXACERBATE THE PROBLEM
AND RESULT IN MORE QUESTIONABLE
REGISTERED VOTES BEING ADDED TO
THE VOTER ROLLS THAN BEING
REMOVED. WHY IS THAT? ONE REASON
MIGHT BE THAT SINCE CITIZENSHIP
IS NOT ALLOWED TO BE CONSIDERED
WHEN DETERMINING ELIGIBLE
VOTERS, IT IS ENTIRELY POSSIBLE
THAT THOSE PEOPLE WHO RECEIVE
THE ERIC REQUIRED VOTER
REGISTRATION INFORMATION CARD
FROM THE SECRETARY OF STATE
BELIEVED THAT THEY WOULD NOT
HAVE RECEIVED THAT INFORMATION
IN THE FIRST PLACE HAD THEY NOT
BEEN ELIGIBLE, AND SHOULD THEY
REGISTER AND EVEN VOTE, THEY ARE
EXEMPT FROM ANY PENALTY OR
LIABILITY THANKS TO THE NEW
CALIFORNIA MOTOR VOTER LAW.
LET'S NOT COMPOUND AN ALREADY
HORRENDOUS PROBLEM BY ADDING
ANOTHER HIGHLY QUESTIONABLE
ELEMENT TO THE MIX. INSTEAD WE
SIMPLY URGE THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO FULFILL HER
RESPONSIBILITY AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND ACTUALLY MAINTAIN
ACCURATE VOTER ROLLS AS REQUIRED
BY FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS.
THAT'S HER JOB. ERIC IS NOT THE
ANSWER. AND I'M ALSO CURIOUS WHY
OUR PREVIOUS LETTERS AND EVEN
THE ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA NAME WAS NOT ON THE
ANALYSIS. I WAS SURPRISED THAT
THERE WAS NO MENTION OF US THERE
BECAUSE WE HAVE WE'VE HAD
OPPOSITION LETTERS SINCE THE GET
GO. WE'LL MAKE SURE AND ADD
THAT. YEAH OKAY. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
BRIEF BREAK AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SINCE WE NOW HAVE A
QUORUM HERE. SO SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
BLAKE SPEER PRESENT. BLAKE SPEER
PRESENT WHEN ONE HERE. ALAN
MENGIBAR NEWMAN, PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO HERE. UMBERG UMBERG
HERE. I'LL TAKE THE EYE ON THE
VOTE. THE BILL. OKAY. THANK YOU.
SO WE NOW NOW HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO ADD
THEIR NAME? GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, RUTH DAWSON WITH
THE ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION.
WE'RE ALSO IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO AB 2050, THOUGH
FOR SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT REASONS
THAN THE FORMER SPEAKER. WE WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND HER
STAFF FOR HER TIME AND
COLLABORATION, AND SEEING
WHETHER WE CAN REACH A MIDDLE
GROUND. UNFORTUNATELY, WE HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION ABOUT
WHICH WAY THE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS LANDS FOR THIS BILL AND
REMAIN OPPOSED. THANK YOU. OKAY.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER LEAD
WITNESS OR LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES? SORRY. SUPPORTIVE
OPPOSITION. THOSE IN OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM I DON'T SEE ANY MORE
OKAY. SO THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. WE'LL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT. NOT SEEING
ANY WE WILL TURN IT BACK TO THE
AUTHOR. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN? WELL,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THIS IS GOING TO BE AN
AMAZING TOOL FOR ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS TO MAKE SURE OUR VOTER
ROLLS ARE UP TO DATE, AND IT
WILL GO INTO EFFECT WHEN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND THE DMV
DETERMINE IT'S THE RIGHT TIME.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON AB 2050? I'LL MOVE IT OKAY.
THANK YOU. THE MEASURE HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR UMBERG AND THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATORS. BLAKE SPEER.
I THINK SPEER. AYE. ONE ONE. NO.
ALLEN. MENGIBAR NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I UMBERG
UMBERG I OKAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. AND WE'LL, WE'LL
LEAVE THAT ON CALL AND IF YOU'D
LIKE TO JUST DO YOUR SECOND
BILL, SINCE YOU ARE ALREADY HERE
AND CAME EARLY, WE APPRECIATE
THAT. I WOULD LOVE TO. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
AND MEMBERS, THIS I'M PRESENTING
AB 2839 THIS YEAR. CALIFORNIA IS
ENTERING ITS FIRST EVER
ELECTION, DURING WHICH
DISINFORMATION THÀNH POWERED BY
GENERATIVE AI WILL POLLUTE OUR
INFORMATION ECOSYSTEMS LIKE
NEVER BEFORE. AND MILLIONS OF
VOTERS WILL NOT KNOW WHAT
IMAGES, AUDIO OR VIDEO THEY CAN
TRUST. SOME OF YOU HAVE PROBABLY
HEARD ABOUT A ROBOCALL THAT WAS
DISSEMINATED BACK IN JANUARY OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN, WHICH
ENCOURAGED VOTERS NOT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PRIMARY
ELECTION IN NEW HAMPSHIRE. THAT
AI GENERATED ROBOCALL WAS A
PRIME EXAMPLE OF NEFARIOUS USE
OF GENERATIVE AI, WHICH SEEKS TO
DISRUPT THE ELECTIONS. THIS TYPE
OF ELECTION DISRUPTION IS NOT
NEW, BUT THE MEANS OF
DISSEMINATING DISINFORMATION
ABOUT AN ELECTION IS MUCH MORE
SOPHISTICATED DUE TO THE ACCESS
TO VERY SOPHISTICATED GENERATIVE
AI PLATFORMS. IMAGINE ANOTHER
EXAMPLE IN WHICH A DEEP FAKE TV
AD DEPICTS AN ELECTION OFFICIAL
SAYING THAT THEY RIGGED THE
VOTES IN FAVOR OF ONE CANDIDATE,
OR A MAIL MAILER SHOWING FALSE
IMAGES OF TAMPERED BALLOTS.
TODAY, IT CAN BE DIFFICULT FOR
THE AVERAGE PERSON TO KNOW WHICH
IMAGES BEFORE THEM ARE REAL OR
FABRICATED. THIS TYPE OF
ELECTION RELATED DISINFORMATION
CAN DRAMATICALLY AFFECT VOTER
BEHAVIOR AND UNDERMINE FAITH IN
OUR ELECTIONS, EVEN IF THEY ARE
LATER DEBUNKED. AB 2839
ADDRESSES THIS GROWING THREAT BY
PROHIBITING BAD ACTORS FROM
DISTRIBUTING DIGITALLY ALTERED
MAILERS, ROBOCALLS, AND VIDEO
ADVERTISEMENTS. ADVERTISEMENTS
THAT ARE INTENTIONALLY DECEPTIVE
TO VOTERS AND DEPICT FALSE
INFORMATION PERTAINING TO
CANDIDATES RUNNING FOR OFFICE,
AN OFFICER CONDUCTING AN
ELECTION, AN ELECTED OFFICIAL,
OR VOTING EQUIPMENT. THESE
CRITERIA WERE CAREFULLY CRAFTED
USING THE INPUT OF STRONG
DEFENDERS OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT, WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT TODAY ARE LEORA
GERSHENSON, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE FOR
TECHNOLOGY AND DEMOCRACY, AND
EVAN MINTON, REPRESENTING VOICES
FOR PROGRESS. THANK YOU. YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M
LAURA GERSHENSON WAS CITED THE
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE FOR
TECHNOLOGY AND DEMOCRACY, A
PROJECT OF CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE. IMAGINE TWO DIFFERENT TV
ADS, ONE SHOWS A BACK ROOM AND
IT SAYS THE CANDIDATE IS UP, IS
UP FOR THE HIGHEST BIDDER.
ANOTHER IS ACTUALLY A DEEPFAKE
OF THE SAME CANDIDATE OF THE
CANDIDATE, BUT IT'S A DEEPFAKE
OF THEM ON CAUGHT ON TAPE
ACCEPTING A BRIBE. ONE YOU MAY
NOT LIKE EITHER OF THEM. ONE IS.
1ST MAY WELL BE MISINFORMATION,
BUT BUT THAT ONE YOU CAN COUNTER
WITH MORE SPEECH. THAT'S WHERE
IT COMES IN. THAT'S NOT TRUE.
HERE'S ALL THE THINGS I'VE DONE
FOR MY DISTRICT. THE OTHER ONE
JUST IS SIMPLY SO BAD THAT ONCE
IT'S SEEN, ONCE IT'S OUT THERE,
IT CAN'T BE UNSEEN AND PEOPLE
WILL TRULY BELIEVE IT. IT'S A
DEEP FAKE. IT'S AN AI GENERATED
IMAGE OF THE CANDIDATE ACCEPTING
A BRIBE. THEY ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT, AND THIS BILL SEEKS
TO ADDRESS THAT. THE GOAL IS NOT
TO BAN ALL SPEECH OR BAN ALL
ELECTION RELATED SPEECH OR ALL
ELECTION RELATED, EVEN
MISINFORMATION. IT'S SIMPLY TO
SAY THAT THERE ARE JUST SOME
THINGS THAT ARE SO BAD THAT THEY
JUST NEED TO BE REMOVED FROM THE
ELECTION ECOSYSTEM. CLOSE TO
ELECTION TIMES, WE'VE WORKED TO
CAREFULLY DRAFT THIS BILL TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT COMPLIES WITH
THE FIRST AMENDMENT SO THAT, YOU
KNOW, SPEECH YOU MAY NOT LIKE,
BUT BUT SPEECH THAT IS ALLOWABLE
UNDER THE FIRST AMENDMENT GETS
THROUGH, AND IT IS ONLY THE TRUE
ADS THAT REALLY TRY TO DEFRAUD
VOTERS AND KEEP THEM FROM VOTING
OR MAKE THEM NOT MAKE THEM VOTE
FOR SOMEONE THEY NEVER INTENDED
TO OR UNDERMINE OUR DEMOCRACY
ARE SIMPLY OUT OF THE ECOSYSTEM,
CLOSE TO AN ELECTION WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI,
EVAN MINTON WITH VOICES FOR
PROGRESS. WE'RE BUSINESS
LEADERS, ENTREPRENEURS,
PHILANTHROPISTS AND MAJOR
DONORS. IMAGINE A MAILER GOING
OUT OF YOU JUST DAYS BEFORE YOUR
NEXT ELECTION, WITH A PHOTO OF
YOU DOING OR SAYING SOMETHING
THAT YOU DIDN'T DO. YOU'RE
HEARING THAT IT'S NEGATIVELY
IMPACTING VOTERS PERCEPTIONS OF
YOU, BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TIME TO
ADDRESS IT OR CORRECT. THE
RECORD I GENERATED
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION IS A GROWING
PROBLEM, AND THE WORLD ECONOMIC
FORUM ACTUALLY STATES THAT IT'S
THE NUMBER ONE THREAT TO THE
WORLD IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
IT'S A PARTICULAR PROBLEM FOR
STATE AND LOCAL ELECTIONS
BECAUSE OF OUR DECLINING LOCAL
PRESS, WHICH MAKES IT A PROBLEM
FOR CANDIDATES TO BE ABLE TO GET
THE WORD OUT ABOUT CORRECTING
THE RECORD. AND THIS IS ALSO A
PARTICULAR ISSUE FOR
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES AND NON-ENGLISH
SPEAKING COMMUNITIES WHO
TYPICALLY RELY ON NON MAINSTREAM
PRESS, WHERE THIS IS A
PERNICIOUS PROBLEM. IN
PARTICULAR, ACCORDING TO THE PEW
CHARITABLE TRUST, VOTER
ENGAGEMENT AND VOTER
PARTICIPATION INCREASE WHEN
THERE IS TRUST AND TRANSPARENCY
IN OUR ELECTIONS, AND THIS BILL
DOES NOTHING MORE THAN INCREASE
TRUST AND TRANSPARENCY IN OUR
ELECTIONS. AND FOR THAT REASON,
WE HAVE A PRIORITY, SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANKS VERY
MUCH. DO WE HAVE MEMBERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT IN
THE ROOM? GOOD MORNING, DOROS
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORT. I ALSO HAVE THE PROXY
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
TO LIKEWISE EXPRESS STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. YOU'RE DYLAN
ELLIOTT ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING, JANICE O'MALLEY
WITH AFSCME CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, TRENT L®NG, CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING, KARABUDA, ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPUTER AND
COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WHERE IN A SUPPORT
IF AMENDED POSITION, ALSO
OFFERING A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE, THANKS.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS JOSE
TORRES CASILLAS, ON BEHALF OF
TECHNET. ALSO IN A SUPPORTIVE,
AMENDED POSITION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WHO WOULD
LIKE TO COME FORWARD?
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS JOE BARRY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION, THÀNH. WE'RE IN AN
OPPOSING, LESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THIS. WE APPLAUD THE EFFORTS
TO LIMIT THE EFFECTS OF AI. THIS
IS SOMETHING BROADCASTERS ARE
DOING AGGRESSIVELY RIGHT NOW TO
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF LOCAL
BROADCASTERS AS A SOURCE OF
ACCURATE INFORMATION, WE HAVE
TWO OBJECTIONS AROUND THE
IMPLEMENTATION ASPECTS OF THIS.
THE BILL REQUIRES US TO ASSESS
WHETHER SOMETHING HAS BEEN
DECEPTIVELY MANIPULATED AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT THAT
MANIPULATION IS GOING TO DECEIVE
AN AVERAGE VIEWER, I'M NOT SURE
HOW AN OBJECTIVE STANDARD CAN BE
APPLIED TO THAT ISSUE AND PUT
STATIONS IN A UNIQUE SITUATION
OF HAVING TO APPLY A DISCLAIMER
TO SOMETHING THAT OTHERS MIGHT
NOT THINK NEEDS ONE. THE SECOND
ISSUE IS THAT DISCLAIMER
APPLICATION THÀNH DIRECTLY
CONFLICTS WITH FEDERAL
REGULATIONS THAT WERE LICENSED
BY THE FCC. CANDIDATES ARE
CANDIDATES ADS. WE ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO EDIT, CENSOR, OR
APPLY ANY SORT OF DISCLAIMER TO.
SO AS WRITTEN NOW, THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE US TO MAKE A
DECISION OF WHETHER WE'RE GOING
TO VIOLATE FEDERAL LAW TO
SATISFY STATE LAW, OR VIOLATE
STATE LAW TO SATISFY FEDERAL
LAW. SO IT PUTS US IN A UNIQUE
SITUATION OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
EVEN ACCEPT ANY OF THE POLITICAL
ADS CANDIDATES, CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATES HAVE AN ABSOLUTE
RIGHT OF ACCESS TO STATIONS.
STATE, LOCAL, CITY ELECTIONS DO
NOT. SO WHAT YOU WOULD FIND IN
THIS IS STATIONS WOULD BE FORCED
TO DENY ALL STATE, LOCAL AND,
COMMUNITY BASED CANDIDATES IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THAT LIABILITY.
AND SO LEADING UP TO THE
ELECTION, THE 120 DAYS
BEFOREHAND, YOU WOULD FIND NONE
OF THOSE ADVERTISING ON LOCAL
RADIO AND TV STATIONS. WE DON'T
THINK THAT FURTHERS THE INTENT
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS IN LIMITING
THIS, OR SERVES ELECTION
INTEGRITY. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES
HERE IN THE ROOM? THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. JACKIE, ON US ON
BEHALF OF DISH AND DIRECT TV
WITH OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, STEPHANIE ESTRADA, ON
BEHALF OF THE MOTION PICTURE
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
THANK YOU. BRANDON KNAPP,
REPRESENTING ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SO THANK YOU TO
ALL OF OUR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. I'D LIKE
TO ASK THE AUTHOR IF WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION
COMMENTARY, IF I MAY HAVE MY
WITNESS RESPOND TO THAT? THAT
WOULD BE GREAT. YES HI. YES, WE
ARE WORKING WITH THE
BROADCASTERS. WE ABSOLUTELY NEED
TO GIVE THEM AN EXEMPTION. THEY
ARE QUITE RIGHT THAT FEDERAL LAW
REQUIRES YOU TO RUN THESE ADS.
WE'RE JUST WORKING ON LANGUAGE.
WE HAVEN'T FULLY AGREED ON
LANGUAGE, BUT THERE IS NO
QUESTION THAT THEY WILL GET AN
EXEMPTION. AND THEY NEED TO GET
THAT EXEMPTION BECAUSE THEY ARE
LIMITED BY FEDERAL LAW. WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
TIGHT AND WHERE FEDERAL LAW
REQUIRES THAT THEY RUN ADS, THEN
THEY RUN THE ADS WITHOUT ANY
NOTICE. BUT IF THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT OF FEDERAL LAW, THEN
THE EXEMPTION WOULDN'T APPLY.
WELL, I GUESS WHAT I WAS MORE
CURIOUS ABOUT WAS THE STATEMENT
THAT THERE WOULD BE NO
ADVERTISEMENT BECAUSE OF
CONCERNS ABOUT LIABILITY FOR
LOCAL AND STATE ELECTEDS IN THIS
PERIOD. AND WHAT WOULD BE THE
RESPONSE TO THAT? WELL, THE
ISSUE IS IF THEY RUN ANY ADS,
THEN THEY HAVE TO RUN ALL OF THE
ADS. SO I THINK THEY WOULD BE
AFRAID THAT IF THEY RAN ANY ADS,
THEY WOULD BE IN TROUBLE. BUT IF
THEY HAVE AN EXEMPTION WHICH
SAYS IF FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES
THAT IF YOU RUN ANY ADS, YOU
HAVE TO RUN ALL THE ADS, THEY
WOULD HAVE THAT EXEMPTION. SO
THEY WOULD RUN ALL OF THEM AND
THEY WOULD NOT BE HELD LIABLE.
THEY WOULD BE COMPLYING WITH
FEDERAL LAW, AND THE ADS WOULD
BE RUN AS IS. OKAY. AND WE JUST
GOT THIS INFORMATION. ACTUALLY,
I JUST GOT IT THIS MORNING. SO
WE ARE DEFINITELY HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THEM AND
COMING UP WITH THAT RIGHT
LANGUAGE. THAT'S GOING TO
ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS. YEAH OKAY.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
YES. SENATOR UMBERG THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, I KNOW
THAT SHOULD THIS BILL PASS AND
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT IT, IT'S
GOING TO GO TO SENATE JUDICIARY.
I'M INFORMED THAT THEY'RE VERY
PERSNICKETY IN THAT COMMITTEE.
CHAIR, ESPECIALLY THE CHAIR.
CHAIR, CHAIR. QUITE PERSNICKETY.
YEAH AND. OKAY. WELL, WE'LL
LEAVE THAT ASIDE. SO ALL RIGHT.
SO I AM LOOKING I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT IT, BUT I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE LANGUAGE WHEN IT
COMES TO SENATE JUDICIARY SO
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS. I I, I DO HAVE GRAVE
CONCERNS THAT, THAT THIS MAY
HAVE, UNWANTED SECOND AND THIRD
ORDER IMPACTS. BUT I THINK WE'LL
GET THERE. OKAY. THANK YOU.
ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. ALL
RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
ABSOLUTELY. SO SENATORS GETTING
THE RIGHT INFORMATION TO VOTERS
IS CRUCIAL TO FUNCTIONING TO A
FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY. AND IT
BECOMES VERY DIFFICULT TO ENSURE
THE INTEGRITY OF THE ELECTION
WHEN CONVINCING DEEPFAKES ARE
SPREAD ONLINE BY PHONE OR
THROUGH THE MAIL TO
INTENTIONALLY MISINFORMED THE
PUBLIC, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON AB 2839? SO
MOVED. OKAY. THANK YOU. SENATOR
UMBERG HAS MOVED THE MEASURE.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
JUDICIARY ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS BLAKE SPEER,
A LAKE SPEER. AYE. ONE ALLEN
MENGIBAR NEWMAN. PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO. AYE. UMBERG UMBERG.
AYE OKAY. IT'S THREE ONE. WE
WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I'M SORRY. IT'S THREE
ZERO. WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
YES NEXT WE WILL TAKE UP OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR QUICKLY. SO
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT ARE TWO
ITEMS AB 453 FROM CERVANTES AND
AB 3284 FROM ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS.
DOES ANY MEMBER WANT TO PULL AN
ITEM FROM CONSENT? IF NOT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS.
OH, WE NEED TO HAVE A MOTION
ACTUALLY FOR CONSENT. OKAY.
SENATOR UMBERG, THANK YOU. HAS
MADE A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATORS BLAKE SPEER.
AYE. WICKS FOR AYE. ONE ONE.
AYE. ALLEN. MENGIBAR NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO LATINA. AYE. UMBERG.
UMBERG. AYE WHAT IS IT? OKAY. IT
WAS FOUR ZERO AND WE WILL LEAVE
IT ON CALL. SO NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO GO BACK TO THE FILE ORDER. SO
WE HAVE AB 1807 FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES. AND YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR MEASURE. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL 1807, WHICH WILL MAKE
UPDATES TO THE EXISTING
RIVERSIDE COUNTY CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION. AS YOU
KNOW, GOVERNOR NEWSOM SIGNED AB
1307 INTO LAW IN 2022. THIS BILL
CREATED THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION, WHICH
IS EMPOWERED TO REDRAW DISTRICT
BOUNDARIES FOR THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. THE
COMMISSION WOULD FIRST BE
CONSTITUTED AFTER THE NEXT
CENSUS IN 2030 AND WOULD BE
CONSTITUTED RECONSTITUTED AFTER
EVERY DECENNIAL CENSUS
THEREAFTER. THE INTRODUCTION OF
AB 1307 KICKED OFF THE CURRENT
WAVE OF COUNTY REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION BILLS THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY SEEING. IN RECENT
YEARS, THIS COMMITTEE HAS
APPROVED INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSIONS FOR
FRESNO, KERN, ORANGE AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTIES, AND THE
GOVERNOR HAS SIGNED ALL THOSE
BILLS INTO LAW. HOWEVER, AB 34
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALENCIA AND
SB 314 BY SENATOR ASHBY CONTAIN
USEFUL INNOVATIONS THAT NONE OF
THE PREVIOUS COUNTY
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION BILLS
INCLUDED. BOTH OF THOSE BILLS
WERE ALSO SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
LAST YEAR. THE PURPOSE OF MY
BILL IS TO IMPORT MANY OF THOSE
INNOVATIONS TO THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION. THIS INCLUDES
UPDATING THE REDISTRICTING
CRITERIA TO REFLECT THE CHANGES
MADE BY THE ENACTMENT OF THE
FAIR'S MAP ACT OF 2023, WHICH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ISAAC BRYANT AND
I AUTHORED. AB 1807 WOULD ALSO
IMPOSE STRONGER PROHIBITIONS ON
THE ABILITY OF COMMISSIONERS TO
HAVE COMMUNICATIONS ABOUT
REDISTRICTING ISSUES OUTSIDE OF
A PUBLIC MEETING OF THE
COMMISSION. THE BILL WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE THE COMMISSION TO
TRANSLATE BOTH ITS WEBSITE AND
MANY OF THE WRITTEN MATERIALS IT
DISTRIBUTES INTO LANGUAGES
SPOKEN BY AT LEAST 3% OF THE
TOTAL VOTING AGE. RESIDENTS OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. THE BILL WOULD
ALSO IMPOSE A MORE RESTRICTIONS
ON THE ACTIVITIES OF
COMMISSIONERS FOR INSTANCE,
THREE YEARS AFTER BEING
APPOINTED TO THE COMMISSION,
COMMISSIONERS WOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO ACCEPT EMPLOYMENT FROM A
CANDIDATE FOR OFFICE OR AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. COMMISSIONERS WILL ALSO
BE PROHIBITED FROM RECEIVING A
NONCOMPETITIVE BID CONTRACT FROM
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. FINALLY, WHILE
SERVING ON THE COMMISSION,
COMMISSIONERS WILL BE BARRED
FROM ENDORSING, WORKING FOR, OR
MAKING FINANCIAL CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE CAMPAIGN OF A CANDIDATE
FOR ELECTIVE OFFICE OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. THESE UPDATES WILL MAKE
THE REDISTRICTING PROCESS FOR
OUR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY FAIRER, MORE
ACCESSIBLE AND MORE TRANSPARENT.
AND, WHEN APPROPRIATE, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO
YOU HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? NOT THIS TIME, NO.
OKAY. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT? GOOD MORNING,
DORA ROSE. LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT. I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR. THESE ARE EXCELLENT
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL AND FOR
BRINGING IT INTO ALIGNMENT WITH
THE FAIR MAPS ACT, WHICH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
CO-SPONSORED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM WISHING TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION? OKAY WE WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS. DOES ANYBODY WANT TO
MAKE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
OKAY. I DON'T SEE ANY. I'LL JUST
MAKE A COMMENT. THIS IS A REALLY
GOOD BILL AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
DESIRE TO MAKE THINGS CONSISTENT
WITH THE FAIR MAPS ACT, AND ALSO
TO MAKE THE RULES CLEAR FOR
THOSE WHO ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES. SO THANK YOU FOR THAT,
AND I'LL BRING IT BACK TO YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE NOW?
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU. DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON AB 1807? ANY
MOTION BY ANY MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY. SENATOR ALLEN
HAS MOVED. THANK YOU. THE MOTION
IS Dð PASS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS. LAKESPUR. AYE, AYE.
ONE ONE. NO. ALLEN. ALLEN AYE.
MENGIBAR. NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE.
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO. AYE.
UMBERG. IT'S FOUR ONE AND WE
WILL LEAVE IT ON. CALL I KNOW
I'M TAKING UP CARILLO. IS THAT
YOU'RE TAKING UP CARRILLO'S
RIGHT NOW? OKAY, THAT'S UNLESS
YOU LIKE ME TO DO THAT, I THINK
I, I THINK WE SHOULD LET
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN GO BECAUSE
HE'S BEEN WAITING PATIENTLY. SO
LET'S JUST COME BACK TO KOREA.
SURE, SURE. NO PROBLEM. OKAY, SO
LET'S, CALL YOU FORWARD.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN AB 544.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. WE ALL
HAVE TO BE IN THREE PLACES AT
THE SAME TIME. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR AND SENATORS, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB 544, WHICH WILL
CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM TO
IMPROVE VOTER PARTICIPATION IN
JAILS FOR INCARCERATED PEOPLE
WHO CURRENTLY STILL HAVE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE. AND BEFORE I
BEGIN, I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON CRAFTING. THE AUTHOR
AMENDS THAT I MADE ON JUNE 11TH
TO ADDRESS MULTIPLE QUESTIONS
AND SUGGESTIONS THAT CAME UP FOR
BOTH THE COMMITTEE AND THE
SECRETARY OF STATE, I'M
COMMITTED TO IDENTIFYING THE
THREE PILOT COUNTIES BY THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE, AND
WE'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT TO FIX THE
TYPO IN THE LANGUAGE. COMMENT
NUMBER FIVE ON THE ANALYSIS.
VOTING FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED OR WHO HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED OF CRIMES HAS BEEN A
HOT TOPIC ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN
RECENT WEEKS. QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER SOMEBODY WHO HAS 34
FELONY CONVICTIONS CAN RUN FOR
PRESIDENT OR EVEN VOTE HAS
SPARKED NEW VOTER INTEREST IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE DIFFERENT,
CONSTITUTIONAL AND STATE LAWS
THAT GOVERN WHETHER PEOPLE CAN
OR CAN'T VOTE. FOR EXAMPLE, IF
YOU ARE CONVICTED OF A FELONY
AND INCARCERATED IN STATE
PRISON, YOU CANNOT VOTE IF YOU
ARE CONVICTED OF A FELONY, BUT
YOU ARE ON SUPERVISION, PAROLE.
YOU CAN VOTE, IF YOU HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED OF A FELONY, BUT
YOU'RE IN THE COUNTY JAIL, YOU
CAN'T VOTE. BUT IF YOU ARE BEING
HELD IN THE COUNTY JAIL BECAUSE
YOU'RE A PRETRIAL AND YOU
HAVEN'T BEEN CONVICTED OF
ANYTHING, YOU'RE JUST TOO POOR
TO BAIL OUT. YOU ABSOLUTELY CAN
VOTE, BECAUSE OF THIS
INCONSISTENCY OR IRREGULARITY,
WE DON'T HAVE KIND OF
STANDARDIZED VOTING STRUCTURES
OR PRACTICES IN ALL OF THESE
PLACES AND SPACES, INCLUDING OUR
COUNTY JAILS. COUNTY JAILS CAN
FACILITATE ELECTIONS, AND SOME
DO, BUT THERE'S NOT A
STANDARDIZED WAY THAT'S DONE.
AND MANY COUNTIES DON'T HAVE THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO ENSURE
THAT ALL ELIGIBLE VOTERS CAN
EXERCISE THEIR CIVIC DUTY AND
PARTICIPATE IN DEMOCRACY FULLY.
IN PRACTICE, MANY COUNTIES HAVE
VOTE BY MAIL PROGRAMS TO
FACILITATE VOTING IN COUNTY
JAILS. HOWEVER, STATISTICS
INDICATE THAT INCARCERATED
PEOPLE A GROUP THAT IS
OVERWHELMINGLY COMPRISED OF LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR,
STILL EXPERIENCE SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS TO VOTING AND ACCESSING
VOTER EDUCATION MATERIALS, WHICH
RESULTS IN VERY LOW VOTER
TURNOUT. AB 544 WILL CREATE A
PILOT PROGRAM THAT WILL PROVIDE
GRANTS TO THREE COUNTIES TO
IMPROVE THEIR VOTING ACCESS FOR
PEOPLE IN JAIL. IT WILL REQUIRE
THE PILOT COUNTIES TO ESTABLISH
A LOCATION WHERE INCARCERATED
PEOPLE CAN VOTE, RETURN THEIR
COMPLETED VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT,
AND UPDATE THEIR VOTER
REGISTRATION, AND CONDITIONALLY
REGISTER TO VOTE. THIS PILOT
PROGRAM WILL BRING US THE
RESULTS THAT WE WILL NEED TO
DEMONSTRATE THE NECESSARY
STANDARDIZED PRACTICES FOR
VOTING IN JAILS ACROSS THE
STATE. OTHER JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE MADE IN-PERSON VOTING
AVAILABLE IN THEIR LOCAL JAIL
FACILITIES HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASED PERCENTAGE OF TURNOUT,
INCLUDING DENVER, WASHINGTON, DC
, COOK COUNTY AND WILL COUNTY IN
ILLINOIS AND HARRIS COUNTY IN
TEXAS. IN FACT, THE STATE OF
COLORADO JUST PASSED LEGISLATION
THAT TURNED EVERY SINGLE JAIL IN
THE ENTIRE STATE INTO A POLLING
LOCATION. THIS BILL TAKES US A
STEP CLOSER TO A DEMOCRACY THAT
INCLUDES EVERYBODY AND CLOSES
THE GAPS IN VOTING ACCESS. HERE
TO TESTIFY WITH ME IS BOB LEIBEL
FROM THE SENTENCING PROJECT AND
ANTOINETTE RATCLIFF WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE. YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, BEFORE I
START MY TESTIMONY, I JUST WANT
TO LEAD WITH GRATITUDE AND
ACKNOWLEDGMENT FOR THE BRILLIANT
MIND THAT ACTUALLY BIRTHED THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. AFTER
WITNESSING FIRSTHAND THE
TRANSFORMATIVE POWER OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND CIVIC
PARTICIPATION WHILE
INCARCERATED. THAT'S TAN TRAN OF
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS, ONE OF OUR PROUD
CO-SPONSORS ON THIS BILL. I AM
ANTOINETTE RATCLIFF, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WITH INITIATED JUSTICE,
ALSO PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF THIS
VERY VITAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
I'M A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA, AND WE ALL KNOW VERY
WELL THAT CALIFORNIA IS
RECOGNIZED FOR OUR BRILLIANT,
VIBRANT AND BEAUTIFUL DIVERSITY
ACROSS OUR COMMUNITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY, THOSE DIVERSE
PERSPECTIVES AND VOICES
CURRENTLY ARE NOT ADEQUATELY
REPRESENTED IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
TODAY, EVERY ELECTION, TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
HAVE THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE ARE
SILENCED BY THE CAGES OF OUR
LOCAL JAILS, DESPITE HAVING THAT
RIGHT TO VOTE, APPROXIMATELY
78,000 PEOPLE IN OUR LOCAL JAILS
FACE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS IN
ACCESSING THAT RIGHT AND CASTING
THEIR BALLOTS. BLACK AND LATINX
PEOPLE MAKE UP 66% OF THAT
POPULATION. I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT THIS IS, IN FACT, AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYAN SAID, OUR
PEOPLE'S CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
VOTE IF THEY ARE NOT SERVING A
STATE OR FEDERAL PRISON TERM FOR
THE CONVICTION OF A FELONY, AND
NEARLY 75% OF OUR STATE'S JAIL
POPULATION CONSISTS OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVEN'T EVEN BEEN CONVICTED
OF OR SENTENCED FOR A CRIME. IN
FACT, PEOPLE CAN BE CAGED FOR
LONGER THAN A YEAR, SOMETIMES
THREE, FOUR, AND FIVE YEARS
PENDING TRIAL DUE MERELY TO
THEIR INABILITY TO AFFORD BAIL.
SOUNDS. SOUNDS SIMILAR TO A
MODERN DAY POLL TAX, ESSENTIALLY
. SO WITH THAT, UNFORTUNATELY,
MANY OF OUR STATE SYSTEMS ARE
INHERENTLY BIASED TOWARDS LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
INHERENTLY RACIST, AND THIS
TARNISHES OUR ELECTORAL SYSTEMS
TO YOU ALL. AS OUR ELECTED
LEADERS HAVE BEEN ENDOWED WITH
THE OPPORTUNITY, OR RATHER, THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO WRITE SOME OF
THESE WRONGS. SO AS THIS
COMMUNITY COMMITS ARGUED HERE
JUST ABOUT TWO MONTHS AGO, THAT
WE NEED TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
FAIR AND HONEST ELECTION SYSTEM
AND DO ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO
TO RESTORE DIGNITY IN THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS. I IMPLORE YOU
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS AB 544
IS ONE MORE CRITICAL STEP IN
THAT RIGHT DIRECTION. WITH THAT,
AS PROUD CO-SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND YOU ALSO HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, I'M BOB LEIBEL HERE
FOR THE SENTENCING PROJECT, A
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION WORKING
FOR FAIR AND EFFECTIVE US
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 544.
ALONG WITH OUR COLLEAGUES, WE
HAVE THREE MAJOR REASONS FOR
SUPPORTING THIS BILL IN LOCAL.
FIRST, ENFRANCHISEMENT IS A IS A
DEMOCRATIC RIGHT AND A RACIAL
JUSTICE ISSUE IN LOCAL JAILS.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE ARE
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE, BUT RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT CONTACT WITH THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM IS FAR
MORE LIKELY TO RESULT IN
DISENFRANCHISEMENT OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN CALIFORNIA. OF THE
97,000 CALIFORNIA CITIZENS WHO
CANNOT VOTE WHILE SERVING A
PRISON TERM, BLACK CALIFORNIANS
ARE TEN TIMES AS LIKELY AS
WHITES TO LOSE THEIR RIGHT TO
VOTE. RESEARCH FINDS THAT WHEN
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE SPEND TIME
IN JAIL, VOTER PARTICIPATION
DECLINES AFTERWARDS AS WELL,
ESPECIALLY AMONG PEOPLE WHO ARE
BLACK AND OR LOW INCOME.
SECONDLY, JAIL BASED VOTING
PROGRAMS ARE SUCCESSFUL. JAIL
BASED POLLING LOCATIONS ARE
BECOMING MORE AND MORE COMMON
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRYAN LAID OUT IN LOCALES
FROM MY HOME STATE OF TEXAS TO
ILLINOIS TO THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA, AND THIS YEAR,
GOVERNOR COLORADO GOVERNOR JARED
POLIS SIGNED SB 2407 TWO, WHICH
MAKES IN-PERSON VOTING AVAILABLE
IN ALL JAILS ACROSS THE STATE.
IN CHICAGO, A JAIL BASED POLLING
LOCATION INCREASED TURNOUT AT
THE COOK COUNTY JAIL FROM 7. IN
THE ABSENTEE BALLOT MODEL TO
OVER 50, THE HIGHEST RATE OF
PARTICIPATION OF ANY POLLING
LOCATION IN THE CITY. LAST YEAR.
VOTING IN THIRD VOTING MATTERS
FOR BETTER PUBLIC SAFETY
OUTCOMES. VOTING HAS A POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH IMPROVED
PUBLIC SAFETY RESEARCH ANALYZED
BY THE SENTENCING PROJECT
SUPPORTS THE LINK BETWEEN
JUSTICE IMPACTED INDIVIDUALS
HAVING THE RIGHT TO VOTE,
EXERCISING THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE,
AND REDUCTIONS IN RECIDIVISM.
THE SENTENCING PROJECT APPLAUDS
THIS COMMITTEE FOR TAKING UP AB
544, AND WE ENCOURAGE ITS
PASSAGE AS A STEP TOWARDS
GUARANTEEING THE RIGHT TO VOTE
FOR ALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHER SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM? MORNING,
DORA ROSE, LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA, VERY PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF THIS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OH, I ALSO HAVE THE
PROXY OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, GLENN BACCHUS FOR THE
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS, PROUD CO-SPONSOR AND
OFFERING THE SUPPORT OF SMART
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS. MARTY LOPEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT HØI EVAN
MINTON. I APOLOGIZE WE WEREN'T
ABLE TO GET OUR LETTER IN ON
TIME. THE VOICES FOR PROGRESS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
EUGENE DE WITH THE CROP
ORGANIZATION AND THE
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS KELLY O'BRIEN WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT. SUSAN
BURTON, GOOD MORNING, RUTH
DODSON WITH ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, SHAINA
ENGLAND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRIS LAWSON, POLICY MANAGER,
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION.
STRONG SUPPORT. YES, SONIA
THOMAS WAS ANTI-RACIST COALITION
IN SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. JACK
CASTELO, A MEMBER OF THE
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION, IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS JESSICA ROBINSON. I'M A
MEMBER OF THE ANTI-RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MY NAME IS HEATHER
SWANNER. I'M WITH THE
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT. JEFFREY
KEENE WITH ANTI-RECIDIVISM
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT. MY
NAME IS MOHAMMED SHAKIR AND I'M
WITH THE ANTI-RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. JASON
BARTLEY, ON BEHALF OF
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION. AND
I'M IN SUPPORT. CÁC SHER, A PART
OF ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT, REVEREND STEVE
HONG PCUSA A SACK AND ON BEHALF
OF GOD OF MATTHEW 25, I'M IN
SUPPORT. OKAY LU█N LEE, ON
BEHALF OF ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MARK SAWYER, ON BEHALF
OF SACRAMENTO AREA CONGREGATIONS
TOGETHER IN STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING. PATTY SHAW. SACRAMENTO
AREA CONGREGATIONS TOGETHER IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT AT MORNING.
ELIZABETH KIM WITH PICO,
CALIFORNIA, REPRESENTING 500,000
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND STRONG SUPPORT. WELL, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO EVERYONE WHO
TOOK TIME OUT OF YOUR DAY TO
COME AND EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL. WE APPRECIATE
HEARING FROM YOU. ARE THERE ANY
OPPOSITION LEAD WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM? ANYBODY WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM
OKAY, NOT SEEING ANY, WE WILL
BRING THIS BACK TO MEMBERS. ANY
COMMENTS, QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
OKAY. THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE A
MOTION, BUT I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING SO
DILIGENTLY ON THIS BILL. AND
BEING WILLING TO IDENTIFY THE
WILLING COUNTIES AND ALSO
SEEKING TO MAKE THIS WORK IN A
TIGHT BUDGET YEAR. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, ANYBODY ELSE? NO.
OKAY. SO GO AHEAD. YOU MAY
CLOSE. NO DEMOCRACY THRIVES WHEN
IT INCLUDES EVERYBODY. YOU KNOW,
MY PERSONAL OPINION IS THAT
REGARDLESS OF YOUR INCARCERATED
STATUS OR CONVICTION STATUS, YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
DEMOCRACY, THAT'S A LARGER
CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW.
CALIFORNIA CODE CURRENTLY ALLOWS
FOR INCARCERATED PEOPLE WHO HAVE
NOT BEEN CONVICTED OF ANY
WRONGDOING, WHO ARE ONLY IN OUR
JAILS BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T
AFFORD TO BAIL OR BOND OUT,
ALLOWS THEM TO PARTICIPATE IN
DEMOCRACY. BUT OUR JAILS ARE NOT
SET UP TO FACILITATE ELECTIONS
IN A HEALTHY AND INCLUSIVE WAY.
THIS BILL LAUNCHES THE PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WILL TAKE US ONE
STEP CLOSER TO THAT THRIVING
DEMOCRACY. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO THE MOTION FROM
SENATOR NEWMAN IS DO PASS, AS
AMENDED BY THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENT ONLY TO PUBLIC SAFETY
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS BLAKE SPEER AYE.
LARKSPUR. AYE. WHEN? WHEN? NO.
ALLEN ALLEN. AYE. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. AYE. NEWMAN NEWMAN.
AYE. PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO. AYE
UMBERG. OKAY. IT'S FIVE ONE AND
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU.
OKAY. NEXT WE ARE GOING TO AB
2355 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARRILLO, BEING PRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS, ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARRILLO AND AS A JOINT
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL, I AM PROUD
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2355.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE A
DISCLOSURE TO BE PROVIDED WHEN
GENERATIVE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE OR AI, IS USED IN
POLITICAL ADVERTISING TO
SUBSTANTIAL ALTER EXISTING MEDIA
OR CREATE CONTENT THAT WILL
FALSELY APPEAR TO BE AUTHENTIC
TO A REASONABLE PERSON IN THE
AVAILABILITY OF TECHNOLOGY TO
EDIT OR ALTER IMAGES. VIDEO AND
SOUND IS NOT NEW. HOWEVER, RAPID
IMPROVEMENTS IN AI AND LARGE
LANGUAGE MODELS THAT ARE CAPABLE
OF GENERATING SOUND IMAGES AND
TEXT HAVE ALREADY RESULTED IN
THE CREATION OF MATERIALS THAT
ARE LIKELY TO PASS OFF AS
CONVINCINGLY REAL, EVEN WHEN
THEY ARE FAKE. IN JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR, A ROBO CALL USING THE
AI GENERATED VOICE OF PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN TOLD NEW HAMPSHIRE
VOTERS TO SAVE THEIR VOTE FOR
NOVEMBER RATHER THAN VOTE IN THE
STATE PRIMARY ELECTION. THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO CREATED THE AUDIO
TOLD TOLD NBC NEWS THAT IT TOOK
LESS THAN 20 MINUTES AND COST
ONLY $1. AS THIS TECHNOLOGY
BECOMES CHEAPER, FASTER AND
EASIER FOR THE PUBLIC TO USE, IT
IS EMBRACED BY CANDIDATES AND
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS ALIKE. ITS
POTENTIAL FOR NEGATIVE EFFECTS
ON DEMOCRACY REQUIRES US TO ACT
AND ACT NOW, IN THIS NEW WORLD
WHERE AI IS BECOMING MORE
COMMONPLACE, WE NEED COMMON
SENSE REGULATIONS THAT RESPECT
FREE SPEECH AND THE SANCTITY OF
POLITICAL EXPRESSION WHILE
PROVIDING GUARDRAILS TO GET
AHEAD. A WIDESPREAD ABUSE OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY. RECENT
AMENDMENTS LIMIT THIS BILL TO
THE ACTIVITIES OF STATE CAMPAIGN
COMMITTEES, AS DEFINED BY THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF 1974 AND
TRANSFER ENFORCEMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES TO THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION.
THIS CHANGE SETS A STRONG
PRECEDENT OF ADDING GENERATIVE
AI DISCLOSURES AS A PART OF THE
EXISTING TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS, WHICH ALREADY
GOVERN POLITICAL ADVERTISEMENT
ON TELEVISION, TEXT MESSAGE AND
SOCIAL MEDIA, JUST TO NAME A
FEW. WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IS TRENT LANG,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TO CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN. THANK YOU. WELCOME.
MR. LANG, YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR
BLAKESPEAR AND MEMBERS TRENT
LANG, PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN.
WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT AB
2355 AND ARE GRATEFUL TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CARRILLO AND CERVANTES FOR
AUTHORING IT. AND TO THIS
COMMITTEE. THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN WAS VERY PROUD TO
SPONSOR THE DIFFERENT CALIFORNIA
DISCLOSE ACT BILLS TO REQUIRE
BALLOT MEASURES AND INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURES TO, CLEARLY
DISCLOSE THEIR TOP FUNDERS. MOST
RECENTLY WITH THE DISCLOSURE
CLARITY ACT BY SENATOR UMBERG
AND ALLEN AND BY THE TEXT
MESSAGE DISCLOSE ACT AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES BEFORE
THE DISCLOSE ACT, VOTERS DID NOT
KNOW, DID NOT USUALLY KNOW, WHO
PAID FOR POLITICAL ADS. THEY
COULDN'T SEE IT. NOW, CALIFORNIA
FACES A SIMILAR PROBLEM WITH
POLITICAL ADS CREATED OR
MANIPULATED BY GENERATIVE AI,
GENERATIVE AI CAN CREATE FAKE
CONTENT THAT CAN DECEIVE VOTERS
INTO BELIEVING SOMETHING
SOMEBODY SAID, SOMETHING THEY
DIDN'T SAY. WAS IT A LOCATION
THAT THEY WERE NOT AT, OR THINGS
THAT HAPPENED DIDN'T ACTUALLY
HAPPEN? THESE DEEPFAKES CAN BE
CONVINCING ENOUGH THAT VOTERS
WOULD NEVER KNOW THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT IS FAKE AND WHAT IS
REAL. AB 2355 WORKS THE SAME WAY
AS THE DISCLOSE ACT. BY
REQUIRING PAID POLITICAL ADS TO
CLEARLY DISCLOSE WHEN THEY WERE
GENERATED BY GENERATIVE AI OR
MANIPULATED WITH IT. JUST LIKE
THE DISCLOSE ACT, THE BURDEN IS
ON THE ADVERTISER WHO KNOWS WHEN
THE CONTENT WAS GENERATED BY AI
PUT IT ON. WE DO BELIEVE THAT A
FEW CHANGES ARE NECESSARY TO ITS
FORMATTING REQUIREMENTS TO MAKE
THEM MORE COMPATIBLE WITH THE
CURRENT DISCLOSE ACT DISCLOSURE
FORMATS, AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IN THIS
COMMITTEE TO DO SO. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT AB 2355
IS NOT A SUBSTITUTE FOR THE TWO
OTHER AI BILLS THAT ARE BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE THAT ADDRESS
OTHER KINDS OF DEEPFAKES THAT
ARE DANGEROUS ENOUGH CLOSE TO
ELECTIONS THAT THEY NEED TO BE
BANNED, AND THAT ALSO ADDRESS
ELECTION COMMUNICATIONS. ALL
THREE BILLS ADDRESS IMPORTANT
PARTS OF THE DANGERS AI POSED TO
ELECTIONS. SO WE HOPE THAT THEY
PASS THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE. WITH THAT, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR THIS IMPORTANT
DISCLOSURE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANY OTHER LEAD WITNESSES?
OKAY. HOW ABOUT WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT?
MADAM CHAIR, MAY I SERVE AS A
LEAD WITNESS FOR THIS? SURE.
SORRY THANK. GET UP QUICKLY
ENOUGH, MY NAME IS KARA. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO COME SIT AT THE TABLE
IF YOU'D LIKE TO. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS KARA BENDER, TESTIFYING
ON BEHALF OF THE COMPUTER AND
COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
2355. CCI IS AN INTERNATIONAL,
NOT FOR PROFIT TRADE ASSOCIATION
WITH ABOUT TWO DOZEN MEMBERS
FROM A RANGE OF COMMUNICATIONS
AND TECHNOLOGY FIRMS. WE COMMEND
CALIFORNIA LAWMAKERS COMMITMENT
TO ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTIONS REMAIN FREE AND FAIR.
THE ADVENT OF GENERATIVE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE CARRIES
GREAT POTENTIAL FOR BENEFICIAL
USES AND IMPACTS TO SOCIETY.
HOWEVER, IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
IDENTIFY AND MITIGATE SPECIFIC
RISKS. THE JUNE 11TH AMENDMENTS
TO AB 2355 WILL HELP TO ENSURE
THAT A COVERED COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATELY INCLUDES
DISCLOSURES FOR CONTENT THAT HAS
BEEN GENERATED OR SUBSTANTIALLY
ALTERED BY AI, WHILE CONTINUING
TO ALLOW FOR OTHER BENEFICIAL
USES. WE APPRECIATE LAWMAKERS
COMMITMENT TO PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTION INTEGRITY
WHILE MITIGATING THE POTENTIAL
RISKS OF GENERATIVE AI. WITH OUR
TARGETED APPROACH AND ARE PROUD
TO SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANKS
VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM? GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR MEMBERS JOSE
TORRES CASILLAS ON BEHALF OF
TECHNET IN SUPPORT. THANKS VERY
MUCH. OKAY. HOW ABOUT LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES? ANYBODY
WISHING TO COME FORWARD, ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN
THE ROOM? OKAY. NOT SEEING ANY,
WE WILL THEN BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU FOR PRESENTING IT ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSEMBLY. MEMBER. OKAY.
WE HAVE A MOTION, I JUST,
BRIEFLY WANT TO SAY THAT I
APPRECIATE THIS BILL ALONG WITH
THE OTHER AI BILLS THAT WE HAVE
COMING FORWARD, THIS COMMITTEE
HELD A JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING TOGETHER WITH THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE AND
TALKING ABOUT AI AND ITS IMPACT
ON ELECTIONS. AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE BILLS THAT MOVE
FORWARD THIS YEAR BECAUSE WE
DON'T WE WANT TO PREVENT THE
MISUSE OF TECHNOLOGY IN
ELECTIONS AS THE LANDSCAPE IS
CHANGING SO RAPIDLY. SO WE NEED
THE RULES TO BE CLEAR, SO THAT
VOTERS AND PARTICIPANTS IN OUR
DEMOCRACY ARE NOT DECEIVED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
BILL. AND WE HAVE A MOTION WHICH
IS DO PASS TO JUDICIARY. AND
IT'S FROM SENATOR MENGIBAR. SO
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OH, ACTUALLY, I'D LIKE TO ASK
YOU TO CLOSE. CERTAINLY. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AS YOU'VE
HEARD, THIS BILL WILL PRESERVE
OUR INTEGRITY AND OUR CONFIDENCE
IN OUR DEMOCRACY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SO LET'S,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS
DUE. PASSED. TWO JUDICIARY
SENATORS, BLAKE SPEAR, Ã
BLAKESPEAR I WHEN ALAN MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I NEWMAN NEWMAN I
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I UMBERG
ALAN I ALAN I. SO IT'S FIVE ZERO
AND WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
OKAY. NEXT WE SEE WE HAVE AN
AUTHOR IN THE ROOM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. HE IS READY AND
PREPARED. AB 2642 IS THE FIRST
BILL TO PRESENT. I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE READY AND PREPARED
PART, BUT I AM HERE. CHAIR BLAKE
SPEAR AND SENATORS CALIFORNIA
HAS ALWAYS BEEN A LEADER WHEN IT
COMES TO PROTECTING OUR
ELECTIONS AND OUR DEMOCRACY.
WHILE OUR STATE HAS STRONG ANTI
INTIMIDATION PROTECTIONS, THERE
IS A CONCERNING TREND THAT'S
GROWING ACROSS OUR COUNTRY OF
INTIMIDATION AND THREATS AGAINST
ELECTION WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY IS NOT IMMUNE DUE
TO THE ALARMING RISE IN THREATS
AND ATTACKS AGAINST ELECTION AND
POLL WORKERS, THERE HAS BEEN A
NATIONWIDE EXODUS OF WORKERS
FROM THE JOB, INCLUDING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE 2024 ELECTION,
44% OF VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA WILL
HAVE A DIFFERENT ELECTION
ADMINISTRATOR THAN THEY HAD IN
THE 2020 ELECTION, MAYBE 2642.
THE PEACE ACT WOULD STRENGTHEN
AND SUPPLEMENT CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING ANTI INTIMIDATION LAWS
BY PROVIDING EXPLICIT CIVIL
PROTECTIONS FOR BOTH ELECTION
WORKERS AND VOTERS.
ADDITIONALLY, AB 2642 WOULD
CREATE AN IMPORTANT PRESUMPTION
THAT PEOPLE WHO OPENLY CARRY
FIREARMS AROUND ELECTION
ACTIVITIES DO SO FOR THE PURPOSE
OF INTIMIDATION. THE BILL HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND YOU
HAVE LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I SEE YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES.
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
LAUREN MILLER, KARALUNAS, AND
I'M AN ATTORNEY AT THE BRENNAN
CENTER FOR JUSTICE AT NYU SCHOOL
OF LAW, A NONPARTISAN
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
PROTECTING AND STRENGTHENING
DEMOCRACY. I'M HERE TODAY TO
OFFER OUR SUPPORT FOR THE PEACE
ACT, THE THREAT OF INTIMIDATION
IN OUR ELECTIONS HAS EXISTED FOR
AS LONG AS OUR COUNTRY HAS HELD
ELECTIONS. BUT EACH AND OVER THE
YEARS, WHAT THAT INTIMIDATION
LOOKS LIKE HAS EVOLVED. BUT EACH
TIME THAT HAS HAPPENED,
LAWMAKERS LIKE YOURSELVES HAVE
STEPPED UP TO CONFRONT THE
PROBLEM. DURING THE
RECONSTRUCTION ERA, FOR EXAMPLE,
INTIMIDATION TOOK THE FORM OF
THE KKK TERRORIZING BLACK VOTERS
AND THEIR ALLIES. SO IN
RESPONSE, CONGRESS STEPPED UP TO
PASS THE KLAN ACT IN 1871,
NEARLY 100 YEARS LATER,
INTIMIDATION TOOK THE FORM OF
LITERACY TESTS AND POLL TAXES
THAT DISENFRANCHIZED BLACK
AMERICANS AND VIOLENCE AGAINST
VOTERS AND VOTING RIGHTS
ACTIVISTS. AGAIN, IN RESPONSE,
CONGRESS PASSED THE FEDERAL
VOTING RIGHTS ACT OF 1965. NOW
WE FACE A NEW THREAT TO OUR
ELECTION SYSTEM, AN EFFORT TO
DISCREDIT AMERICAN ELECTIONS AND
THE PEOPLE WHO RUN THEM. AND
ONCE AGAIN, IT HAS LED TO A NEW
FORM OF INTIMIDATION, WIDESPREAD
AND OFTEN RACIST ALLEGATIONS OF
UNPROVEN FRAUD ARE DRIVING
VIOLENCE AND THREATS DIRECTED AT
ELECTION OFFICIALS, POLL WORKERS
AND VOTERS. TODAY, I ASK YOU TO
FOLLOW IN THE FOOTSTEPS OF OUR
FOREBEARS BY PASSING THE PEACE
ACT, WHICH WOULD MAKE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES TOWARDS
ADDRESSING THIS NEW THREAT.
CALIFORNIA, LIKE ALL STATES,
MAKES IT A CRIME TO INTIMIDATE A
VOTER OR ELECTION OFFICIAL. YET
ONLY TWO STATES ALLOW THOSE
VOTERS OR OFFICIALS THEMSELVES
TO SUE FOR DAMAGES. PRIVATE
ENFORCEMENT IS VERY EFFECTIVE AT
DETERRING BAD BEHAVIOR. WHAT
BETTER USE OF IT THAN
SAFEGUARDING OUR DEMOCRACY?
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD THE NATION
BY TAKING THIS IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARDS PROTECTING ITS VALUED
CIVIL SERVANTS AND VOTERS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
BLAKE. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
I'M DEAN LOGAN, THE REGISTRAR,
RECORDER, COUNTY CLERK FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2642. ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY, I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN FOR AUTHORING THE
BILL AND FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
SUPPORT OF ELECTIONS,
ADMINISTRATION AND INTEGRITY IN
CALIFORNIA, CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
A LEADER IN CRAFTING ELECTIONS,
LAWS AND REGULATIONS THAT
ADVANCE VOTER PARTICIPATION AND
TRANSPARENCY, EQUITABLE ACCESS
AND SECURITY. AB 2642 ADDS
IMPORTANT PROVISIONS TO
STRENGTHEN PROTECTIONS FOR
VOTERS, ELECTION WORKERS, AND
OFFICIALS, PROVIDING IMPORTANT
TOOLS TO HOLD THOSE WHO SEEK TO
INTIMIDATE, HARASS, AND HARM
THEM RESPONSIBLE. IN MANY
RESPECTS, AB 2642 IS A BILL I
WISH WAS UNNECESSARY.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE CURRENT
NARRATIVE AROUND ELECTIONS AND
THE PROLIFERATION OF MISSED DIS
AND MAL INFORMATION HAS RESULTED
IN NOTABLE INCREASE IN
THREATENING ACTIVITIES, ONLINE
HARASSMENT AND INTIMIDATION OF
THOSE RELIABLE WE RELY UPON TO
ENSURE FREE AND FAIR ELECTIONS
OVER THE COURSE OF 2020, 2021
AND 2022 ELECTION CYCLES, I WAS
SUBJECTED TO A BARRAGE OF ONLINE
HARASSMENT AND EXPERIENCED ON
MORE THAN ONE OCCASION,
DISRUPTION IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD BY
PROTESTERS OUTSIDE MY HOME,
DRIVEN BY INACCURATE AND
SENSATIONALIZED CLAIMS OF FRAUD
AND ELECTION DENIALISM. MY
OFFICE HAS HAD TO INCREASE
SECURITY AND RESPONSE TO THOSE
THREATS AND HARASSMENT THAT WERE
RECEIVED BY MAIL, EMAIL, SOCIAL
MEDIA AND OVER THE PHONE. SADLY
AND SHOCKINGLY, I KNOW OF
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
FAR MORE AGGRESSIVE ACTIVITY
WHICH HAS RESULTED IN THE LOSS
OF EXPERIENCED DEDICATED
ELECTION ADMINISTRATORS AND
ELECTION WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE AND THE COUNTRY. THE
NARRATIVE SPEEDING THIS ACTIVITY
HAVE NOT SUBSIDED AND IN FACT
SHOW SIGNS OF ESCALATION. THEY
HAVE BEEN CONTINUOUS SINCE THE
2020 ELECTION CYCLE, AND THEY
REPRESENT A THREAT TO THIS
YEAR'S ELECTION. WHILE
CALIFORNIA HAS EXISTING CRIMINAL
LAWS THAT PROHIBIT THREATS AND
HARASSMENT AGAINST VOTERS AND
ELECTION WORKERS, AB 2642 ADDS
THE ADDITIONAL DETERRENT AND
PROTECTION OF PRIVATE ACTION
WHEN AND IF THREATS OF
INTIMIDATION ARE CARRIED OUT,
RESULTING IN PERSONAL HARM OR
DAMAGE TO TARGETED ELECTION
WORKERS AND VOTERS. THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR REPRESENTATIVE
FORM OF GOVERNING DEPENDS ON
FREE AND FAIR ELECTIONS. THE
VOTING PROCESS BELONGS TO OUR
ELECTORATE AND MUST BE CONDUCTED
WITH TRANSPARENCY AND INTEGRITY,
INCLUDING PUBLIC OBSERVATION AND
QUALITY ASSURANCE, TO ENSURE
ELECTIONS ARE CARRIED OUT IN
THAT MANNER. VOTERS, OFFICIALS
AND ELECTION WORKERS NEED THE
ASSURANCE AND PROTECTION THAT
ALLOWS FOR THOSE PROCESSES TO
OCCUR WITHOUT DISRUPTION,
INTIMIDATION OR HARM. AB 2642
OFFERS A REASONABLE AND
EFFECTIVE DETERRENT TO THOSE WHO
WOULD SEEK TO DISRUPT AND DAMAGE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE, PEOPLE AND
PROCESSES. WE RELY ON TO SUPPORT
THE VOTING FRANCHISE. FOR THOSE
REASONS, AND WITH THE
APPRECIATION FOR THE VOICE OF
THIS BODY, WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND BEING WILLING TO
SHARE YOUR PERSONAL STORY. I'M
SORRY THAT YOU WERE HAVING TO GO
THROUGH THAT. THANK YOU FOR
PERSEVERING AND COMING TODAY, DO
WE HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES WHO
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT?
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING, JAMIE
MINER, ON BEHALF OF GIFFORDS.
I'M PROUD TO CO-SPONSOR THIS
LEGISLATION AND PLEASED TO
SUPPORT. THANKS DOROS LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
VERY STRONG SUPPORT ALSO OF THE
PROXY OF DISABILITY RIGHTS.
CALIFORNIA. ALSO IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY CHAU
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. HIÂU
JANICE O'MALLEY, ASC CALIFORNIA.
HERE IN SUPPORT. DANNY OFER WITH
EVERYTOWN FOR GUN SAFETY AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU, RUTH
DAWSON, ACLU, CALIFORNIA ACTION
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
MARQUIS MASON, CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO
WE HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? ANY OTHER PEOPLE
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION?
YOU MAY COME FORWARD NOW. OKAY.
NOT SEEING ANY. THEN WE WILL
RETURN IT TO THE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS. YES, SENATOR NEWMAN,
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. SO, TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN, THANK
YOU. I APPRECIATE THIS, BILL AND
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL. I
ACTUALLY DID LEGISLATION A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO TO EXTEND,
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS TO ELECTION WORKERS
AS THE WITNESS MENTIONED. I
THINK THIS IS A SENSIBLE
ADDITION, ESPECIALLY GIVEN WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT YEARS
AROUND ELECTION RELATED THREATS
AND VIOLENCE, I AS WELL
APPRECIATE THE WITNESSES
WILLINGNESS TO BE HERE TODAY.
GLAD TO SUPPORT THE BILL. I'D
ASK TO BE ADDED AS A AS A
COAUTHOR AS IT MOVES FORWARD.
AND I'M GLAD TO MOVE IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU,
SENATOR NEWMAN. SENATOR NGUYEN
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I JUST I
JUST HAVE I MEAN, I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND I AND I
UNDERSTAND IT AND THANK YOU FOR,
YOU KNOW, CONTINUING TO STAND UP
FOR OUR ELECTION PROCESS. MY, MY
QUESTION, I GUESS, IS, DOES THIS
STOP PEOPLE FROM IF THERE IS A
QUESTIONS OF THE ELECTION, DOES
IT STOP AND NOT ALLOW PEOPLE TO,
YOU KNOW, ASK, YOU KNOW, TO
QUESTION A RECOUNT, TO QUESTION,
YOU KNOW, A SPECIFIC PRECINCT,
TO EVEN MAYBE SUE THE REGISTRAR
OF VOTERS? I MEAN, BECAUSE
THAT'S ANOTHER I'M LOOKING AT
MORE THE LEGAL ASPECT OF IT,
DOES IT COMPLETELY SHUTS DOWN
AND NO ONE CAN SAY ANYTHING AT
ALL. I MEAN, I DON'T WANT PEOPLE
IN FRONT OF MY HOUSE OR YOUR
HOUSE EITHER, RIGHT? I MEAN, WE
ALL FACE WE FACE THAT IN THE
PAST, AND SO IT'S MORE OF WHAT
AVENUE DOES PEOPLE HAVE IF THEY
HAVE A QUESTION ON WHETHER, HEY,
WAS THAT LEGITIMATE OR NOT, HOW
WHAT ARE THE PROCESSES THERE
LEFT FOR THEM? THANK YOU.
SENATOR, I THINK, I THINK IT'S I
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION. AND I DON'T THINK
THAT THIS BILL INTENDS TO TAKE
AWAY, AS I SAID IN MY TESTIMONY,
THE TRANSPARENCY AND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PUBLIC TO
OBSERVE AND TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE
THOSE WHO, CONDUCT THE ELECTION
PROCESS. THAT PROCESS BELONGS TO
THE VOTERS. AND THERE ARE
EXISTING PROCEDURES IN LAW TO
ALLOW FOR THAT TO AS YOU
INDICATE, TO ASK FOR A RECOUNT
TO THROUGH PUBLIC RECORDS
REQUESTS OR TO SIMPLY BE PRESENT
AND CHALLENGE DECISIONS THAT ARE
MADE BY ELECTION OFFICIALS. I
THINK WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
FOCUSES ON THE POTENTIAL
ESCALATION OF THOSE ACTIVITIES.
IF YOU'RE NOT DOING THAT IN AN
APPROPRIATE MANNER, IF YOU'RE
NOT DOING IT THROUGH THE LEGAL
CHANNELS THAT ARE ALREADY
DEFINED TO DO THAT. AND AS YOU
SAY, THAT HAPPENS ON A REGULAR
BASIS, UNFORTUNATELY, WE'VE SEEN
IN SOME CASES THAT'S WHERE THAT
ESCALATION OCCURS. SO THIS THIS
WOULD ADDRESS THE ESCALATION OF
GOING BEYOND THOSE LEGAL
PARAMETERS TO FORM OF, OF
HARASSMENT OR INTIMIDATION THAT
WOULD MAKE PEOPLE FEARFUL FROM
CARRYING OUT THEIR DUTIES AND
JUST TO JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT VERY GOOD ANSWER. IT ONLY
APPLIES TO THINGS THAT ARE
INTIMIDATING, THREATENING OR
COERCIVE, UNDER A REASONABLE
PERSON STANDARD. OKAY. THANK
YOU. YES, SENATOR ALLEN, OR LET
ME MAKE SURE SENATOR NGUYEN IS
OKAY. SENATOR ALLEN, I WANT TO,
I'LL MOVE THE BILL WHEN
APPROPRIATE. APPRECIATE IT. I
MEAN, IF ONLY I GUESS. OH, YOU
DID IT. OKAY OKAY, MOVE IT
AGAIN. YEAH, IT'LL BE A WE'LL
MOVE. YOU KNOW, I, I MEAN, I, I
WISH THAT THIS BILL WOULD SOLVE
THE PROBLEM THAT, THE REGISTRAR
RECORDER HAS MENTIONED. I MEAN,
OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
THING FOR US TO DO, BUT THE, THE
PROLIFERATION OF MISINFORMATION
AND THE INTERACTION WITH
VIOLENCE AND THE POTENTIAL FOR
VIOLENCE IS VERY FRIGHTENING.
AND THE IDEA THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
PEOPLE WHO STEP FORWARD IN
PUBLIC SERVICE TO JUST FAIRLY
MANAGE OUR ELECTORAL SYSTEMS
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE KIND OF
RIDICULOUS AND DANGEROUS AND
FRIGHTENING HARASSMENT,
THREATENING AND INTIMIDATION
THAT THAT YOU HAVE HAD TO GO
THROUGH IS JUST IS ATROCIOUS.
AND, AND I WISH, YOU KNOW, AND
UNFORTUNATELY, YOU'RE NOT THE
ONLY ELECTION OFFICIAL IN THE
COUNTRY WHO'S GONE THROUGH THIS.
WE KNOW IT'S HAPPENING ALL OVER
THE PLACE, AND IT'S A DANGEROUS
THING. IT'S A DANGEROUS THING.
AND I WANT TO, EXPRESS MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. AND I
JUST HOPEFUL THAT, WE'RE ABLE TO
DO MORE TO PROTECT OUR ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS. AND I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU AND EVERYONE ELSE WHO
WORKS IN THIS SACRED SPACE FOR
PERSEVERING AND CARRYING ON.
AND, MAINTAINING YOUR COMMITMENT
TO A STRONG, FAIR, OPEN, FREE,
TRANSPARENT AND JUST DEMOCRACY.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? I COULDN'T HAVE
SAID IT BETTER MYSELF, AND I
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT THIS IS A
PROBLEM THAT'S IMPACTING,
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS AND OFFICERS
OF ALL DIFFERENT PARTIES, THE
PRIOR COMMITTEE I HAD TESTIFYING
A REPUBLICAN ELECTION OFFICIAL
WHO'S FACED HARASSMENT, AND
THEIR TEAM HAS FACED HARASSMENT.
THESE ARE ELECTIONS OFFICIALS,
PROFESSIONALS WHO JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR OUR DEMOCRACY
IS STRONG, THAT OUR BALLOTS ARE
COUNTED IN A FAIR WAY, THAT
EVERYBODY GETS A CHANCE TO
PARTICIPATE, AND LIKE, THE
SENATORS MENTIONED, YOU KNOW,
THE THEY SHOULDN'T BE FACING THE
HARASSMENT THEY'RE FACING, AND
THIS WILL JUST BE ONE MORE LAYER
OF PROTECTION, BUT BUT I DON'T
THINK IS A PANACEA, RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANKS VERY
MUCH. THANKS SENATOR NEUMANN WAS
GOT THERE FIRST WITH THE MAKING
THE MOTION. SO THE MOTION IS Dð
PASS TO JUDICIARY AND IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR NEUMANN. SO,
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS BREAKSPEAR I BLAKESPEAR
I11. NO. ALLEN I ALLEN I
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NEWMAN I
NEWMAN I PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I
UMBERG. FIVE ONE IT'S FIVE ONE
AND WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND NEXT WE
HAVE A SECOND BILL. WE HAVE A
SECOND BILL BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AB 2655. THANK YOU, CHAIR
BLAKE. AND SENATORS, FIVE YEARS
AGO, I AUTHORED THE FIRST
ELECTION DEEPFAKE BILL IN THE
NATION, AND AS YOU HEARD WITH
THE PRESENTATION OF A BILL
EARLIER, JUST A FEW SHORT YEARS
LATER, THE TECHNOLOGY IS BETTER,
CHEAPER, AND MORE WIDELY
ACCESSIBLE. AND WE'RE SEEING
DEEPFAKES USE TO UNDERMINE
ELECTIONS ACROSS THE GLOBE. AND
HERE IN AMERICA, THERE HEREFORE
I'M AUTHORING AB 2655 TO PROTECT
ELECTION INTEGRITY BY REQUIRING
LARGE ONLINE PLATFORMS TO, FOR A
LIMITED TIME, RESTRICT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF MATERIALLY
DECEPTIVE CONTENT INTENDED TO
AFFECT THE OUTCOME OF AN
ELECTION, UNDERMINE CONFIDENCE
IN ELECTION RESULTS OR HARM THE
REPUTATION OF A CANDIDATE FOR
LESS HARMFUL YET STILL
MATERIALLY DECEPTIVE CONTENT.
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
PLATFORMS TO LABEL IT AS AN
ELECTION AS ELECTION
DISINFORMATION. WITH TODAY'S
SOPHISTICATED DEEPFAKES, VOTERS
MAY NOT KNOW WHAT AUDIO OR
VISUAL CONTENT THEY CAN TRUST,
WHICH CAN UNDERMINE ELECTION
INTEGRITY. IMAGINE IF A FAKE
VIDEO APPEARED ONLINE OF AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL DOING OR SAYING
SOMETHING THAT THEY DID NOT DO
OR SAY, LIKE ACCEPTING A BRIBE
OR SAYING THAT THEY'D HACKED
VOTING MACHINES TO ENSURE THEIR
OWN VICTORY. THE BILL DOES NOT
DEMAND PERFECTION. WHAT IT SAYS
IS THAT PLATFORMS MUST ACT USING
THE BEST AVAILABLE TOOLS IF THEY
KNOW OR SHOULD KNOW, THAT THE
CONTENT MEETS THE TEST. IN THE
BILL, PLATFORMS CANNOT BURY
THEIR HEAD IN THE SAND, BUT IF
THEY DON'T KNOW, THEN THERE IS
NO OBLIGATION. I RECOGNIZE THAT
THIS BILL IS LEGISLATING IN AN
ARENA WHERE TECHNOLOGY AND THE
LAW ARE FAST EVOLVING, AND THIS
CAN BE CHALLENGING, BUT DOING
NOTHING IS NOT AN OPTION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY ARE LARA
GERSHENZON AND DAVID HARRIS,
BOTH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR TECHNOLOGY AND
DEMOCRACY. THANK YOU AND
WELCOME. YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. LARA
GERSHENSON WITH CITED THE
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE FOR
TECHNOLOGY AND DEMOCRACY, WHICH
IS A PROJECT OF CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE. IMAGINE TWO
DIFFERENT VIDEOS THAT ARE GOING
VIRAL ONLINE. ONE IS AN
INFLUENCER ON TIKTOK SAYING
DON'T VOTE BY MAIL. IT'S BAD.
YOU MAY NOT GET YOUR BALLOT
COUNTED. GO IN PERSON. THE OTHER
IS THE ELECTION OFFICIAL IN YOUR
COUNTY, A DEEPFAKE OF THEM
SAYING DON'T VOTE BY MAIL. WE
THROW THEM ALL OUT. THERE ARE
TWO FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
THINGS. BOTH ARE DESIGNED TO
IMPACT THE VOTE AND IMPACT WHO
VOTES. BUT ONE, YOU CAN COUNTER
WITH MORE INFORMATION. YOU CAN
HAVE. YOU CAN HAVE SAYING NO,
COME AND VOTE. THE OTHER ONE IS
JUST SO BAD, SO FUNDAMENTALLY
BAD THAT HAVING IT OUT THERE,
EVEN IF IT HAD A LINE ON THE
BOTTOM THAT SAID THIS IS AI IS
SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH, THAT IT JUST
SHOULDN'T BE IN THE ECOSYSTEM,
BECAUSE ONCE IT'S OUT THERE, IT
IS IMPOSSIBLE TO TAKE BACK. AND
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO DO THAT,
IS TRYING TO SAY THE WORST OF
THE WORST ELECTION DEEPFAKES.
THOSE ARE THE CANDIDATE OR THE
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL OR AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL DOING OR SAYING
SOMETHING THEY DIDN'T DO OR SAY
WITH THE INTENT TO INFLUENCE THE
ELECTION, THAT COMES UP JUST
SHOULDN'T BE THERE FOR A SHORT
TIME FRAME AROUND THE ELECTION,
AND OTHER THINGS IN A LONGER
TIME FRAME SHOULD BE SHOULD BE
LABELED AS SUCH. THE BOTTOM LINE
IS, THERE ARE JUST THINGS THAT
CANNOT BE UNSEEN AND WILL IMPACT
OUR DEMOCRACY. AND WHETHER
PEOPLE VOTE OR NOT. AND WE HOPE
AND PRAY THAT THIS IS ENOUGH TO
BE ABLE TO, THAT THIS BILL AND
THE OTHER BILLS THAT YOU'RE
HEARING ARE ENOUGH TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S DEMOCRACY. WE URGE
YOU TO VOTE AYE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YES. GO AHEAD, CHAIR BLAKE
SPEER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. IT'S AN HONOR TO BE
HERE SPEAKING WITH YOU. MY NAME
IS DAVID HARRIS, AND I'M A
SENIOR POLICY ADVISOR TO CITED
THE CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE FOR
TECHNOLOGY AND DEMOCRACY. I AM
ALSO CHANCELLOR'S PUBLIC SCHOLAR
AT UC BERKELEY, WHERE I TEACH
CLASSES AT THE HAAS SCHOOL OF
BUSINESS ON TOPICS INCLUDING AI,
ETHICS FOR LEADERS, AND CIVIC
TECHNOLOGY. I PREVIOUSLY WORKED
FOR CLOSE TO FIVE YEARS AT
FACEBOOK AND META ON THE CIVIC
INTEGRITY AND RESPONSIBLE AI
TEAMS. I'VE ALSO ADVISED THE EU,
THE WHITE HOUSE, NATO AND THE
UNITED NATIONS ON ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE. THIS BILL ONLY
APPLIES TO THE LARGEST ONLINE
PLATFORMS WITH THE GREATEST
REACH OF POTENTIAL ELECTION
MISINFORMATION, AND IT'S FULLY
IMPLEMENTABLE TODAY. BASED ON
TOOLS, THE COMPANIES ALREADY
POSSESS. ILLEGAL CONTENT IS
COMPLEX. CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE
MATERIAL, TERRORIST CONTENT.
THIS BILL IS VERY NARROW AND
MAKES IT IMPERMISSIBLE TO
GENERATE ELECTION
DISINFORMATION. THE COMPANIES
HAVE ALREADY SHOWN THAT THEY CAN
DO IT WITH THOSE OTHER TYPES OF
CONTENT. SOME OF THESE COMPANIES
SUGGEST THAT THE REQUIREMENTS
CANNOT BE MET, BUT THEY ALREADY
ARE UNDER SIMILAR REQUIREMENTS
IN EUROPE DUE TO EUROPE'S
DIGITAL SERVICES ACT, WHICH IS
DESIGNED TO, AMONG OTHER THINGS,
CRACK DOWN ON ELECTION
INTERFERENCE. SO THEY ARE
ALREADY COMPLYING THERE OR
TRYING TO. THEY'VE ALSO PROMISED
TO DO THESE SAME TYPES OF
REASONABLE THINGS THAT THE BILL
PROVIDES, THAT THE TECH
COMPANIES MADE A BIG COMMITMENT
IN THE AI AND ELECTIONS ACCORD
AT THE MUNICH SECURITY
CONFERENCE. THIS PAST FEBRUARY.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, THE
COMMITMENTS THAT THE TECH
COMPANIES HAVE MADE IN PLACES
LIKE THAT ARE VOLUNTARY, HAVE NO
TIMELINES FOR IMPLEMENTATION AND
HAVE NO ACCOUNTABILITY
MECHANISMS ASSOCIATED WITH THEM.
THE GOOD NEWS, THOUGH, IS THAT
AI COMPANIES AND SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN PUBLICLY
CALLING FOR MORE REGULATION OF
THEIR INDUSTRY, AND REGULATION
IS GREAT IN THIS FIELD BECAUSE
IT CREATES A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
WHERE ALL THE COMPANIES HAVE TO
PLAY BY THE SAME RULES. WITHOUT
REGULATIONS LIKE THIS, YOU
PUNISH THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
WORKING HARD TO OPERATE IN THE
INTERESTS OF SOCIETY AND I'LL
CLOSE BY SAYING THAT WE SHOULD
HEED THE CALL OF TECH INDUSTRY
CEOS CALLING FOR REGULATION AND
PROMISING TO DO BETTER FOR
DEMOCRACY AND GIVE THEM WHAT
THEY ARE ASKING FOR. WITH AB
2655. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER SUPPORT IN THE ROOM?
PLEASE COME FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD MORNING. DOROS
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
AND I HAVE THE PROXY OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS. CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS JANICE
O'MALLEY ASKED ME CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, DYLAN
ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI, EVAN
MINTON, VOICES FOR PROGRESS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. TRENT L®NG,
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
IN SUPPORT. MARCUS MASON,
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. THANKS OKAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
HELLO. WELCOME. COME FORWARD.
YOU MAY START WHEN READY. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. GREAT. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN. MY NAME IS KARA
BINDER. ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPUTER AND COMMUNICATIONS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB
2655, CTIA AND ITS MEMBERS TAKE
SERIOUSLY THE IMPACT DECEPTIVE
CONTENT MAY HAVE ON ELECTIONS,
AS MANY OF OUR MEMBERS, AS NOTED
EARLIER, ARE WORKING TO
IMPLEMENT TOOLS TO BETTER DETECT
AND LABEL AI GENERATED CONTENT
AND USING A COMBINATION OF AI
AND HUMAN REVIEW, THEY MODERATE
CONTENT AND VIOLATION OF THEIR
TERMS OF SERVICE, INCLUDING
CONTENT THAT IS ILLEGAL AND
POTENTIALLY HARMFUL. BUT THE
TOOLS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE ARE NOT ALWAYS
RELIABLE OR ACCURATE. AND WHILE
SUCH TECHNOLOGY IS EVOLVING, SO
ARE THE MEANS FOR BAD ACTORS TO
EVADE SUCH DETECTION. BECAUSE
COVERED PLATFORMS ARE NOT PRIVY
TO THE INTENT AND CONTEXT TO
WHICH A PIECE OF CONTENT IS
USED, THEY COULD INADVERTENTLY
OVER BLOCK OR OVER LABEL
CONTENT. THIS COULD RESULT IN
USER FRUSTRATION AND SUPPRESSION
OF POLITICAL SPEECH. POLITICAL
SPEECH WAS AT THE CORE OF WHY
OUR FIRST AMENDMENT WAS
ESTABLISHED. THEREFORE,
RESPONSIBILITY FOR LABELING AI
GENERATED ELECTION CONTENT AND
LIABILITY FOR DECEPTIVE CONTENT
SHOULD REST WITH THE ENTITY THAT
PUTS FORTH SUCH MATERIAL, THE
ONE THAT IS MOST AWARE OF THE
INTENT AND CONTEXT TO WHICH THE
CONTENT WAS CREATED AND SHARED.
WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BREADTH OF THE BILL, WHILE
ESTABLISHES DEFINED TIME PERIODS
SURROUNDING ELECTION AND
ELECTION PROCESSES FOR NEWLY
ESTABLISHED PROHIBITIONS AND
REQUIREMENTS. CGRTS. THE BILL
DOES NOT SPECIFY WHICH ELECTIONS
WHERE. AS NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS, THIS COULD RESULT IN
PLATFORMS BEING REQUIRED TO
BLOCK CONTENT ALMOST CONSTANTLY
IN ORDER TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE.
WE APPRECIATE THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT THE PRA TO A
CANDIDATE FOR ELECTIVE OFFICE,
ELECTED OFFICIAL OR ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL IN LIEU OF ANY RESIDENT
OF CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER, WE'RE
STILL CONCERNED THAT THIS COULD
STILL RESULT IN THE
WEAPONIZATION OF POLITICAL
SPEECH THAT COMPETING CANDIDATES
DISAGREE WITH. FOR EXAMPLE,
UNDER THE DIGITAL MILLENNIUM
COPYRIGHT ACT, THERE IS STUDIES
DESCRIBING POLITICAL AD
TAKEDOWNS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM. AFTER
RECEIVING REPORTS OF COPYRIGHT
INFRINGEMENT, MANY OF THESE
CASES WERE ULTIMATELY DEEMED
FAIR USE, BUT PLATFORMS WERE
INCLINED TO IN TAKING DOWN THE
CONTENT LEST THEY FACE
LIABILITY. FOR THESE REASONS, WE
URGE A NO VOTE ON THIS
LEGISLATION. ON BEHALF OF CTIA,
I APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM? GOOD MORNING. RUTH
DAWSON WITH ACLU, CALIFORNIA
ACTION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. JOSE
TORRES CASILLAS, ON BEHALF OF
TEGNA AND CHAMBER OF COMMERCE,
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
BRANDON KNAPP, REPRESENTING
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION,
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE WILL
NOW BRING IT BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS. AND I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
AUTHOR, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND TO ANY OF THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES STATEMENTS, APPRECIATE
THE CONCERNS. WE'VE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER, HAVING A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS SINCE SINCE THE DAY
WE INTRODUCED THE BILL, YOU
KNOW, I, WE BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
NARROWLY TAILORED THE BILL TO
ADDRESS A SIGNIFICANT GOVERNMENT
INTEREST. WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
WE'VE, YOU KNOW, PUT, LANGUAGE
IN THERE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PLATFORMS AREN'T HELD TO A
PERFECT STANDARD. BUT BUT YOU
KNOW, THAT THERE IF THEY FOR THE
BIG PLATFORMS THAT THE BILL
APPLIES TO THAT THEY ARE USING
BEST PRACTICES THAT AS ONE OF MY
WITNESSES MENTIONED, THEY'RE
ALREADY USING FOR, OTHER USERS
IN OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD. AND
SO BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WE'LL
ABSOLUTELY CONTINUE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND LOOKING FOR WAYS
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE THAT DON'T TOTALLY
UNDERMINE OR GUT THE PURPOSE OF
THE BILL. AND I'M SURE MY
WITNESSES, IF GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY, MIGHT ALSO HAVE
SOME THOUGHTS. BUT THROUGH THE
CHAIR, I MEAN, IF YOU'D LIKE TO
BRIEFLY, I JUST WANTED TO GIVE
YOU A CHANCE. THE ONLY THING I
WOULD ADD IS THE LIABILITY UNDER
THIS BILL IS JUST INJUNCTIVE
RELIEF. SO ALL IT IS, IS A COURT
TELLING THE PLATFORM TO TAKE
DOWN WHAT THEY SHOULD HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN DOWN. THERE IS NOT
MONETARY LIABILITY THANKS TO
SECTION 230. I JUST LIKE TO
RESPOND RESPECTFULLY TO THE
POINT RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION
THAT THE TOOLS ARE NOT RELIABLE
OR ACCURATE. THERE ARE WELL
ESTABLISHED TOOLS FOR DOING
THIS, AND THAT'S WHY WHEN YOU
OPEN UP YOUR FACEBOOK NEWS FEED
OR YOUR INSTAGRAM FEED, YOU
GENERALLY WILL NOT FIND, CHILD
SEXUAL ABUSE, TERRORIST
RECRUITING CONTENT BECAUSE THEY
CAN REMOVE THAT TYPE OF CONTENT.
THERE'S NO FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THAT TYPE OF
CONTENT AND THIS TYPE OF
CONTENT, EXCEPT THAT THIS TYPE
OF CONTENT IS NOT YET ILLEGAL
AND THAT'S WHY THE COMPANIES ARE
NOT DOING IT. THEY WILL DO IT IF
FORCED TO. ELON MUSK GOT RID OF
ABOUT 81% OF TWITTER'S STAFF
AFTER HE ACQUIRED IT. MARK
ZUCKERBERG SAID PUBLICLY THAT HE
ADMIRED WHAT A LEAN COMPANY ELON
HAD BEEN ABLE TO MAKE TWITTER,
AND THAT'S BECAUSE ACTIVIST
INVESTORS ARE SAYING CUT, CUT,
CUT, MAKE YOUR COMPANIES MORE
PROFITABLE. ONLY DO WHAT YOU'RE
LEGALLY REQUIRED TO DO, AND IT
IS ON US. AND YOU, MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, TO MAKE IT
LEGALLY REQUIRED TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. OKAY. WELL, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I APPRECIATE THAT,
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU. AND I
GUESS I'D LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION
OF THE OPPOSITION. SO, MISS
BENDER, YOU HAPPEN TO BE AT THE
TABLE. SO APOLOGIES. YOU'RE
REPRESENTING ALL OF THOSE NICE
FOLKS, BUT BUT I WOULD YOU AGREE
OR DISAGREE THAT THIS IS, IN
FACT, A FAIRLY URGENT MATTER,
GIVEN THE ADVANCES IN AI AND THE
PROSPECTIVE THREAT TO OUR
ELECTIONS. EXCUSE ME. AGREED
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS
THE IMPACTS THAT I MAY HAVE ON
ELECTIONS, BUT I BELIEVE THAT IS
WHY WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
OTHER MEASURES THAT PUT THE
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE PRODUCING THE CONTENT THAT
IS, IN FACT, DECEPTIVE OR THEY
KNOW WHY, HOW THEY HAVE PRODUCED
IT AND IN WHAT CONTEXT THEY HAVE
PRODUCED IT. TO BACK UP A LITTLE
BIT ON THAT FRONT, WHILE THE,
RESPECTFULLY, THE, THE SUPPORT
WITNESS OVER HERE MENTIONED THAT
THE REASON WHY WHEN YOU OPEN UP
FACEBOOK AND YOU'RE NOT SEEING A
BUNCH OF CSAM, I WOULD ARGUE
THAT THAT'S A FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT, AND NOT APPLES TO
APPLES COMPARISON. AS CCR
MATERIAL KI¾M IS IDENTIFIED
USING HASHING VALUES THAT ARE
FOUND AT A DATABASE, WHICH IS
NOT THE CASE FOR SOMETHING THAT
MAY BE CONSIDERED MORE
SUBJECTIVE WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHETHER A SPECIFIC PERSON
SAID OR DID SOMETHING. AND I
THINK THAT'S MORE DIFFICULT FOR
A PLATFORM TO KNOW DEFINITIVELY
WHETHER SOMEBODY, YOU KNOW,
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, THERE ARE
OVER 7000 STATE LEGISLATORS IN
THE COUNTRY, WHETHER THAT
SPECIFIC CANDIDATE DID SAY OR IN
FACT, DO SOMETHING. SO I DO
THINK THAT THOSE ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT EXAMPLES
THAT ARE BEING SHARED. I
APPRECIATE THAT, BUT I GUESS THE
USE CASE THAT THE AUTHOR'S
TRYING TO ADDRESS, YOU KNOW, I
REGARD AS A REAL PROBLEM AND,
AND AT LEAST VISUALLY, NOT HARD
TO IDENTIFY ONCE IDENTIFIED TO
THE SUPPORT POSITIONS POINT.
IT'S REALLY A WORK FACTOR
QUESTION. RIGHT. AND SO THE
QUESTION AT ISSUE HERE IS, YOU
KNOW, WHAT'S THE WILLINGNESS OF
THE MAJOR PLATFORMS TO DO THIS
WORK. AND IN THE ABSENCE OF THIS
LEGISLATION, HOW CAN WE BE
ASSURED, AS REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE PUBLIC INTEREST, THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO DO THAT WORK? SO THIS
SEEMS, IN THE ABSENCE OF AN
ALTERNATIVE, I'D BE INTERESTED
TO HEAR AN ALTERNATIVE SOLUTION.
SEEMS LIKE A VERY REASONABLE
MEASURE. SO DO YOU HAVE IS THERE
A BETTER WAY TO DO THIS THAT
GETS AT THE ISSUE? BECAUSE I
THINK THE ISSUE IS FAIRLY CLEAR
CUT. AGAIN, I THINK IT'S ABOUT
GOING AFTER THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PRODUCING THE MATERIAL
ORIGINALLY. OKAY, THAT IS A
WHACK A MOLE PROPOSITION, UNLESS
YOU DO THAT AT A SYSTEMS LEVEL.
OKAY, YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW, WAS
INTERESTED TO HEAR, BUT HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT
FORM. THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION? OKAY. SENATOR
NEWMAN, THANK YOU. THIS IS Dð
PASS TO JUDICIARY ASSISTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATORS.
SHAKESPEARE, A SHAKESPEARE I
WHEN? NO. ALLEN ALLEN I MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I NEWMAN NEWMAN I
PORTANTINO UMBERG. IT'S FOUR ONE
AND WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO NOW WE ARE ON TO
OUR LAST ITEM OF THE DAY HERE
FOR THESE ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE. IT'S ACA EIGHT. WE
WILL ASK ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON
TO COME FORWARD.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
SENATORS, I'M PLEASED TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY REGARDING
ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT, ACA EIGHT, THE END
SLAVERY IN CALIFORNIA ACT, THIS
IS A CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS PRIORITY AND A PART
OF OUR REPARATIONS PACKAGE. I
FIRST WANT TO START BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I
APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION OF YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, AND YOUR PREDECESSOR, AS
WELL AS THE STAFF WHO'VE WORKED
REALLY HARD TO GET US TO THIS
POINT. ALSO NOTING THAT WHILE
WORKING THROUGH THESE AMENDS, WE
DID HAVE, LOCAL GOVTS BRING UP
POTENTIAL IMPACTS AS IT RELATES
TO JAILS. SO WE ARE WORKING WITH
THEM TO ADDRESS THEM, AND IT MAY
BE AN AK EIGHT OR OUR COMPANION
BILL AB 628, SO THIS IS JUST AN
FYI. SO BACK TO ACA EIGHT. THIS
MEASURE WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIANS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO AMEND ARTICLE
ONE, SECTION SIX OF THE STATE
CONSTITUTION TO PROHIBIT SLAVERY
IN ANY FORM WITHOUT AN EXCEPTION
. TODAY, SLAVERY TAKES ON MODERN
FORMS, AS NOTED ON THE US
DEPARTMENT OF STATE SITE
WEBSITE, THE MODERN FORM OF
SLAVERY AS IT RELATES TO
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE INCLUDES
SEX TRAFFICKING, CHILD SEX
TRAFFICKING, FORCED LABOR,
BONDED LABOR, OR DEBT BONDAGE,
DOMESTIC SERVITUDE, FORCED CHILD
LABOR, UNLAWFUL RECRUITMENT, AND
USE OF CHILD SOLDIERS. SO IN ANY
FORM, SLAVERY WOULD BE
PROHIBITED HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AND IT SHOULD BE
NOTED THAT BECAUSE IT'S WRONG IN
ALL FORMS, CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE
EXPLICITLY CLEAR IN DENOUNCING
THAT IN OUR CONSTITUTION,
CALIFORNIA IS AMONG ONLY 16
STATES WITH AN EXCEPTION CLAUSE
FOR INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE IN ITS
STATE CONSTITUTION. MOST
RECENTLY, VOTERS IN ALABAMA,
OREGON, TENNESSEE, AND VERMONT
REMOVED INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE
LANGUAGE FROM THEIR STATE
CONSTITUTIONS, INCARCERATE
PEOPLE HAVE LONG FACED CRUEL
TREATMENT FOR ANY WORK ABSENCES.
THIS INCLUDES PHYSICAL VIOLENCE,
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT, DENIAL OF
PHONE CALLS AND FAMILY VISITS,
AND LIMITING PARTICIPATION IN
SELF-HELP GROUPS AND
DISCIPLINARY WRITE-UPS THAT
RESULT IN LONGER PRISON TERMS.
SUCH PUNISHMENTS ARE. THREATS OF
SUCH PUNISHMENTS ARE OFTEN USED
EVEN WHEN ABSENCES ARE DUE TO
ILLNESSES OR INJURIES SUSTAINED
THROUGH THE WORK. THE CURRENT
PRACTICE OF FORCED LABOR DOES
NOT PREPARE INCARCERATED PEOPLE
FOR SUCCESS UPON REENTRY, AND
OFTEN PREVENTS PARTICIPATION IN
REHABILITATE SERVICES. LET ME
SAY IT A DIFFERENT WAY
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES SHOULD
NOT BE FORCED LABOR, AND FORCED
LABOR SHOULD NOT BE
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES.
INCARCERATED PEOPLE'S
RELATIONSHIP TO WORK SHOULD NOT
BE ONE OF EXPLOITATION AND
LITTLE TO NO AGENCY. CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO END SLAVERY IN EVERY
SINGLE FORM, INCLUDING
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE. NOW AND
WE NEED TO GIVE THE VOTERS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR CONSTITUTION
TO REFLECT OUR VALUES. NOW, WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS LAWRENCE
COX, ON BEHALF OF THE LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN, AND REVEREND DAVIS
WILLIE WILES, FROM SAINT MARK'S
UNITED METHODIST CHURCH. THANK
YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU. YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU FOR
COMING. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
I'D LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU. IT'S
AN HONOR AND A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE. I'M HERE REQUESTING YOUR I
VOTE I AM SYSTEM IMPACTED, LIKE
SHE SAID, MY NAME IS LAWRENCE. I
AM THE REGIONAL ADVOCACY AND
ORGANIZING ASSOCIATE FOR ALL OF
US OR NONE. I MANAGE OUR EIGHT
CHAPTERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
I'M ALSO A COORDINATING LEAD,
OUR COALITION FOR FAMILY UNITY,
WHICH IS A GROUP OF 30 NON
PROFIT ORGS THAT WORK IN
ADVOCACY WORK THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I'VE SPENT THE LAST 17
YEARS OF THE LAST 19 YEARS OF MY
LIFE. I SPENT 17 OF THEM
INCARCERATED. I AM A TESTAMENT
TO WHAT REHABILITATION LOOKS
LIKE. I'VE SUCCESSFULLY
DISCHARGED PAROLE IN CONJUNCTION
WITH ALL THE THINGS THAT I JUST
MENTIONED EARLIER. LIKE THE
MEMBER SAID, FORCED LABOR IS NOT
REHABILITATION. I'VE BEEN
SUBJECTED TO FORCED LABOR. I AM
SYSTEM IMPACTED. SO I UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT MEANS NOT TO HAVE YOUR
AUTONOMY AND YOUR OWN AGENCY. I
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A
STRANGE FROM SOCIETY AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT REHABILITATION
COURSES DO. I HAVE BEEN FORCED
TO WORK JOBS AND HAD JOBS TO
WHERE I COULDN'T GET OUT THOSE
JOBS, EVEN WHEN I WANTED TO TAKE
MY OWN SIGN COLLEGE COURSES TO
COMPLETE MY DEGREE. FORCED LABOR
WAS PRIORITIZED OVER MY
REHABILITATION, AND THEN THE
EXCUSE THAT I WAS GIVEN WILL
DON'T GO TO WORK AND GET THREE
WRITE UPS AND THEN WE'LL DROP
YOU. SO THERE'S NO OPPORTUNITY
FOR INDIVIDUALS INCARCERATED TO
CHOOSE WHAT THEIR PRIORITY AND
WHAT THEIR REHABILITATION
PROCESS ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE. I
REQUEST I VOTE, I THINK AS A
SOCIETY, OUR CONSTITUENTS SHOULD
BE ALLOWED TO DECIDE WHETHER WE
WANT TO STILL PRACTICE SLAVERY,
AND WE WANT OUR CONSTITUTION TO
SAY THAT WE PRACTICE SLAVERY. IF
WE PRIORITIZE BEING A SLAVE FREE
STATE, HOW CAN WE ALLOW THE LAST
FEW REMNANTS OF SLAVERY? AND I'M
GONNA KEEP CALLING IT SLAVERY
AND INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE,
BECAUSE LET'S JUST BE HONEST,
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IT IS. SO
WHY ARE WE HERE IN 2024? STILL
PRIORITIZING, ALLOWING THE LAST
REMNANTS OF SLAVERY TO STILL
EXIST AND JUST SAY, OKAY, IT'S
BECAUSE THEY'RE CONVICTED OF A
CRIME THAT THEY DESERVE TO LOSE
THEIR HUMANITY. AND THIS BILL IS
NOT ABOUT WAGES. THIS BILL IS
JUST SIMPLY ABOUT AUTONOMY. IF
YOU'RE PRIORITIZING
REHABILITATION, WE CAN'T
PRIORITIZE REHABILITATION
WITHOUT GIVING INDIVIDUALS THEIR
OWN AGENCY. YOU CAN'T HAVE A
PERSON TRYING TO REHABILITATE
THEIR SELF, AND THEY CAN'T MAKE
THEIR OWN DECISIONS BECAUSE WHEN
WE COME INTO SOCIETY, WE'RE
MAKING OUR OWN DECISIONS.
THERE'S NO ONE FORCING US TO DO
ANYTHING. AND IT'S NOT THAT
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO WORK.
PEOPLE WANT TO WORK. NO ONE
WANTS TO SIT IN A CELL ALL THE
TIME. PEOPLE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
BE MOVING AND BE ACTIVE. NO ONE
WANTS TO BE SUBJECTED TO A DARK
CELL, BUT IT'S LET ME CHOOSE
WHAT I DO. LET ME CHOOSE WHAT I
WORK. IF I WANT TO GO TO SCHOOL,
LET ME GO TO SCHOOL BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO BETTER
ME. THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO HELP
ME INCREASE MY LIKELIHOOD OF
MAINTAINING GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT.
ONCE I HIT THE STREET AND I, I
PLEAD WITH YOU TO PROVIDE YOUR I
VOTE BECAUSE ACA IS IMPORTANT.
THIS IS A HISTORIC MOMENT. THIS
IS TIME FOR US TO SHOW LIKE WE
USUALLY SHOW THE REST OF THE
STATES THAT WE ARE PROGRESSIVE,
THAT WE SUPPORT SOCIETY, THAT WE
SUPPORT HUMANITY. AND ACA IS A
HISTORIC TIME AND A HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO DO SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. YOU ALSO HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD AFTERNOON.
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS REVEREND
QUINTESSA DAVIS WILES AND I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT A COUPLE OF
THINGS BEFORE I CAME INTO MY
ROLE AS A CLERGY PERSON, I SPENT
OVER TWO DECADES AS A CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER, WORKING WITH POLY
COMPLEX TRAUMA IN THE INNER
CITIES, AS WELL AS AN ORGANIZER
WORKING WITH DISPOSSESSED AND
DISENFRANCHIZED COMMUNITIES. I
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGE BEFORE
US IS WE LOOK AT THIS INHERITED
LANGUAGE, THE BLESSING AND
BEAUTY OF YOU AS POLICYMAKERS
AND LEGISLATORS AND DECISION
MAKERS IS THAT YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. YOU INHERITED SOME
LANGUAGE THAT IS NOT YOURS. OUR
FOREFATHERS AND DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE. LET US KNOW THAT
IF WE WERE TO DO ANYTHING IN
THIS COUNTRY WORTHWHILE, IF WE
RUN UP AGAINST ANY KIND OF
SYSTEMIC PROBLEM THAT IS HARMFUL
OR DISPOSSESSES ANY HUMAN BEING,
WE ARE TO TRANSFORM IT THROUGH
THE VOTE OF THE PEOPLE. AND I
INVITE YOU TO REMEMBER THAT
LANGUAGE. AND I WANT TO POINT
OUT TO YOU THAT INCARCERATED
PEOPLE STILL HAVE RIGHTS, AND
THEY HAVE NEEDS. THEY'RE
VULNERABLE DESPITE WHAT WE THINK
. THEY HAVE LITTLE TO NO POWER.
AND IF WE ARE GOING TO BE AN
EXAMPLE AS A LAND OF
OPPORTUNITY, IF WE'RE GOING TO
BE AN EXAMPLE AS LAWMAKERS, IF
WE IF WE WANT REHABILITATION TO
TRULY BE A THING, WE NEED TO BE
MINDFUL OF THIS EXCEPTION
LANGUAGE THAT IS STILL IN OUR
CONSTITUTION. IT IS GLOSSY
LANGUAGE. IT IS FLUFFY LANGUAGE
THAT IS MEANT TO MAKE PEOPLE
FEEL GOOD UNDER THE GUISE OF
SUBJUGATION. THERE IS NO SUCH
THING AS INDENTURED SERVITUDE.
IT'S CALLED SLAVERY. THAT
DOESN'T CHANGE WHAT IT IS
BECAUSE IT IS DRESSED UP
BEAUTIFULLY. MY HOPE TODAY IS
THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT AND PASS
ACA EIGHT THE END SLAVERY IN
CALIFORNIA ACT AND REMOVE THE
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE LANGUAGE
FROM THE STATE'S CONSTITUTION.
CORRECT THE SYSTEMIC EVIL. AND
I'M USING THE WORD EVIL ON
PURPOSE. IT IS A SOCIAL
INJUSTICE. IT NEEDS TO BE
ABOLISHED AND ITS EXPLOITIVE. WE
MONETIZE BODIES OF INCARCERATED
PEOPLE UNDER THE GUISE OF
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE PROPERTY OF
THE STATE. THEY ARE NOT
PROPERTY. THEY'RE HUMAN BEINGS.
THEY DESERVE TO BE HUMANIZED.
THEY DESERVE TO HAVE A CHOICE TO
DO THEIR WORK. THEY DESERVE TO
BE RECOMPENSED. SO IF THEY ARE
GOING TO WORK, I WOULD I WOULD
ASK US TO CONSIDER WHAT JOB
TRAINING AND CREDIT LOOKS LIKE.
IF THEY'RE GOING TO WORK, THEY
NEED TO PUT IT ON THEIR RESUMES
WHEN THEY COME HOME. WE NEED TO
EQUIP THEM TO TRANSITION BACK
INTO SOCIETY. REENTRY DOESN'T
START WHEN THEY COME HOME.
REENTRY STARTS BEFORE THEY
LEAVE. THEY ARE NOT JUST MAKING
AN AMENDS TO WHOMEVER THEY
OFFENDED, BUT IT IS BUILDING
CHARACTER. IT IS LEARNING NEW
SKILLS AND IT IS HAVING PERSON,
PERSONAL AGENCY AND WE ALL HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THEM MAKE
THAT DIFFERENCE. SO I REALLY DO
APPEAL TO YOU TO STAY, TO ALLOW
THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE INCARCERATED
TO BE TREATED WITH DIGNITY. ACA
REMOVES THE LAST VESTIGE OF
LEGALIZED INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE
IN CALIFORNIA, AND CAN SET THE
STAGE FOR REHABILITATION AND
REDEMPTION. I DON'T HAVE TO TELL
YOU, AS SENATORS, CALIFORNIA IS
A GAME CHANGER. PEOPLE FOLLOW
US. THEY LOOK TO US FOR
LEADERSHIP. LET'S LEAD AND MAKE
HISTORY. LET'S REMOVE SLAVERY
FROM OUR CONSTITUTION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO BOTH OF YOU FOR
YOUR MOVING TESTIMONY. WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO SUPPORT WITNESSES
NOW AND FOR SUPPORT WITNESSES.
WE HAVE A LOT INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE. WE APPRECIATE YOU
COMING TO SHARE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS. SO YOU ITS NAME, TITLE,
AND IF YOU SUPPORT, JESSE
BURLESON, IN CUSTODY PROGRAM
COORDINATOR LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND ALL
OF US AND NONE 31 YEARS
INCARCERATED I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU THÀNH NIELSEN HEARING
ON SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
HAWAII NAACP IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ED LITTLE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND STRONG SUPPORT,
DYLAN ELLIOTT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANDY LEBENSBAUM, ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS, IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS LAWSON, POLICY MANAGER AT
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION, IN
STRONG SUPPORT, ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE COALITION FOR ADJUSTING
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA LINEAGE
EQUITY AND ADVANCEMENT PROJECT,
CALIFORNIA BLACK LINEAGE
SOCIETY, AMERICAN REDRESS
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA, BAY
AREA, AMERICAN REDRESS COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA, SACRAMENTO, ALL
IN STRONG SUPPORT, Ó
CO-SPONSORS, AND OF COURSE, ON
BEHALF OF THE GLIDE
ORGANIZATION, ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. I DON'T KNOW. JERONIMO
AGUILAR HERE, ON BEHALF OF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN AND ALL OF US ARE
KNOWN, WE ARE VERY PROUD
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AS WELL.
ALSO WANTS TO, READ OFF OTHER
CO-SPONSORS. INTERFAITH MOVEMENT
FOR HUMAN INTEGRITY, THE YOUTH
LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE, BEND THE
ARC, A NEW WAY OF LIFE, CARAVAN
FOR JUSTICE, FREEDOM FOR YOUTH,
LEGAL AID AT WORK, CALIFORNIA
NATIVE VOTE PROJECT, THE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED AND
CONVICTED PEOPLE AND FAMILIES
MOVEMENT. WORK SAFE ASIAN
PRISONER SUPPORT COMMITTEE, AND
ABOLISH BONDAGE COLLECTIVELY.
THANK YOU. MORNING, DR. ROSE.
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORT. AND I ALSO HAVE THE
PROXY OF INITIATE JUSTICE ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
EUGENE DE, POLICY ASSOCIATE WITH
THE CROP ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT
AND ARC POLICY TEAM MEMBER ALSO
IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION.
CARMEN NICOLE COX, DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS, ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION PROUD
CO-SPONSOR. GOOD MORNING, DEBRA
SANDERS. WITH COUNTLESS
CALIFORNIA AND THE ALLIANCE FOR
REPARATIONS, RECONCILIATION AND
TRUTH AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. DÍAS. MY NAME
IS GABRIEL MURILLO, FORMERLY
INCARCERATED. I'M WITH ALL OF
US. NONE AND LSPC, FULLY SUPPORT
. ANY CHILD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
. GOOD MORNING. KELLY O'BRIEN
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. PROUD TO BE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ACA EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING. PATTY SHAW FROM
SACRAMENTO ACT AND THE NINE
FEDERATIONS OF PICO CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT. HI EVAN
MINTON WITH VOICES FOR PROGRESS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HELLO, MARK SAWYER WITH
SACRAMENTO ACT AND STRONG
SUPPORT. REVEREND STEVE HONG,
ORDAINED CLERGY WITH PCUSA
SACRAMENTO ACT. WITHOUT RESPECT
TO THOSE WHO OPPOSE THIS WITH
DISCRIMINATION TOWARDS THE POOR
AND THE OPPRESSED ON BEHALF OF
GOD OF MATTHEW 25, I SUPPORT AND
JANET NGUYEN IS A COWARD. HI
JOHN CANNON WITH LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
A MEMBER OF ALL OF US ARE NUN
FORMERLY INCARCERATED AND STRONG
SUPPORT, RAYMOND GÓMEZ I'VE BEEN
A SLAVE SINCE I WAS 15 YEARS
OLD. I'M A SILICON VALLEY DEBUG
COALITION FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE SAN JOSE
BRANCH OF THE NAACP. AND WE
SUPPORT. JASON BARTLEY, ON
BEHALF OF ANTI-RACIST RACISM
COALITION, FULL SUPPORT THIS ACA
JEFFREY KEENE WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. HELLO. MY NAME IS
MOHAMMED SHAKIR AND I'M
REPRESENTING ARC AND I'M FULL
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. JACK CASTELO, A MEMBER OF
THE ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION.
AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THIS BILL. CÁC SCHER, MEMBER OF
THE ARC COALITION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. MY NAME IS JESSICA
ROBINSON. I'M WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING.
YESENIA THOMAS IN SUPPORT FROM
ARC SACRAMENTO ELIZABETH KIM,
FORMERLY INCARCERATED LAWYER AND
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR PICO
CALIFORNIA, IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING, GLEN BACCHUS FOR
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HEATHER SWINTON FROM ARC
ANTI-RECIDIVISM COALITION,
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING, HENRY ORTIZ,
FORMERLY INCARCERATED CHAPTER
ORGANIZER WITH ALL OF US IN
SACRAMENTO AND LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACA. THANK YOU
. CARLOS HERNANDEZ WITH MEATBALL
COLLECTIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT. LÀ
AUSTIN OCAMPO, FORMERLY
INCARCERATED UC BERKELEY ALUMNI.
STRONG SUPPORT. HI, I'M RAVEN
JONES WITH COMMUNITIES UNITED
FOR RESTORATIVE YOUTH JUSTICE OR
COURAGE HERE AS PROUD
CO-SPONSORS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
HI, NATHAN SALINAS, FORMERLY
INCARCERATED WITH COURAGE.
STRONGLY SUPPORT. HI I'M BERNICE
SINGH ROGERS, AN OUTSIDE
ORGANIZER WITH INITIATE JUSTICE
AND INMATE FAMILY COUNSELOR AT
SALINAS VALLEY. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. HI. HI. JOSE HERRERA
FROM COURAGE, I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI, MACKEY.
ARE YOU HERE WITH COURAGE. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT. HELLO, DAISY
CARRILLO. LOPEZ WITH COURAGE.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT. RUTH
MCELHANEY WITH SAINT MARK'S
UNITED METHODIST CHURCH. I
STRONGLY SUPPORT ALSO A FORMER
STAFF MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE. DEBORAH SLOAN, STAFF
ATTORNEY. FOR LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND ALL
OF US OR NONE. I'M A CONSTITUENT
OF ASSEMBLYMAN WILSON AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT ACA. THANK YOU.
LINA DIN LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND ALL
OF US ARE NUN FORMERLY
INCARCERATED IN STRONG SUPPORT.
EILEEN BELL, VOLUNTEER FOR LEGAL
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN AND I VERY
STRONGLY SUPPORT. JIM LINDBERG,
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
. LARA LARIOS, OUT WITH OUTSIDE
ORGANIZING WITH INITIATE JUSTICE
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT. MÐI
HIDALGO WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
STRONG SUPPORT. HANNAH KHN WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS BROOKE
LEE. I'M WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS MITRA. I'M A MEMBER
OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN AND CONSTITUENT OF
SENATOR LARKSPUR, AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT. PEACE AND
BLESSINGS TO YOU ALL. MY NAME IS
TAKUYA BONNER. I'M THE HOUSING
ADVOCATE FOR ALL OF US AND NONE,
WHICH IS A PROJECT OF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN. AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT. I'M SIENNA COBURN WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING, ROBERT BOWDEN ON
BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
STRONG SUPPORT. HAZEL WATSON,
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH SAC ACT
AND STRONG SUPPORT. SOPHIE FROM
ACT SACRAMENTO AND I SUPPORT ACA
SYDNEY FONG ON BEHALF OF ASIAN
AMERICANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
FOR CIVIC EMPOWERMENT AND STRONG
SUPPORT. MY NAME IS NÓI GUDINO
AND I'M HERE WITH LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS, WITH CHILDREN AND
ALL OF US ARE NONE AND PROUD
CO-SPONSORS, SUPPOSED
CO-SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. AND WE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI, I'M
CHRISTINA KEENE, ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR WITH COMMUNITY HEALERS
AND I'M HERE WITH ALL OF US OR
NONE. I'M ALSO A MOTHER, AND I
HAVE KIDS THAT ARE IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION, INCLUDING MYSELF,
POLICE ARRESTED MY SON FOR NO
REASON AND THEN LET HIM DIE ON
THE FLOOR IN FRONT OF MY
DAUGHTER AND TOLD HER IT WAS
NORMAL. SO BUT I AM A VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL, AND
I ASK THAT YOU GUYS CONTINUE
DOING THE SAME. THANKS ALYSSA
MOORE. LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND
STRONG SUPPORT. WELL, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, EVERYBODY FOR COMING
AND EXPRESSING YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. ARE THERE
ANY LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES?
SEEING NONE. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION? OKAY. I WANT
TO MAKE SURE AND INVITE MY TWO
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUES TO SAY
ANYTHING IF THEY WANTED TO. NO.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO? YES. YOU
MAY APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. I'M
REGGIE JONES-SAWYER, PAST CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS AND A MEMBER OF THE
TASK FORCE THAT BROUGHT THIS TO
YOU. AND I'M FIRMLY, YOU KNOW, I
SPENT TWO YEARS OF MY LIFE
WORKING ON THIS, BRINGING THIS
TO. AND I THANK THE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN FOR BRINGING IT
IN. I REALLY ORPHALI ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. WE'RE HAPPY
TO SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOAN
SAWYER AND WEBER HERE. THANK YOU
FOR COMING, WITH THAT, WE'LL
TURN IT BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES.
IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
ANY COMMENTS. YES. SENATOR
ALLEN, I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING REALLY HARD
WITH THE BOTH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND WITH THE COMMITTEE ON THIS
ISSUE. AND, I, YOU KNOW, I
UNDERSTAND THE CONVERSATIONS ARE
GOING WELL AND, I THINK IN THE
END OF THE DAY, AS WE DISCUSSED
ON A TOTALLY DIFFERENT MATTER
YESTERDAY, IT'S ALL ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION AND TRYING TO
CREATE A SYSTEM THAT WORKS, FOR
THE STATE. AND SO I THINK THAT
THOSE CONVERSATIONS ARE VITALLY
IMPORTANT. IT'S PART OF WHAT'S
GOING TO GET THIS THING ACROSS
THE FINISH LINE SUCCESSFULLY.
AND I JUST I'M HAPPY TO HEAR
ABOUT THE PROGRESS. I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO KEEP THOSE CONVERSATIONS
GOING. AND, IT'S WITH THAT
UNDERSTANDING, I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU SIR, THANK YOU. AND I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT OUR
FOUNDATIONAL DOCUMENT OF THE
CONSTITUTION REFLECT OUR HIGHEST
IDEALS AND I APPLAUD YOU FOR
CARRYING THIS FORWARD. AND I
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY WHO CAME
TODAY TO SPEAK. YES. AND AS
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. I ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH
YOUR COMMENTS. BUT JUST A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS HERE WITH RESPECT
TO WORK ASSIGNMENTS, AS I
UNDERSTAND IT, THAT SOMEONE WHO
IS INCARCERATED COULD STILL BE
REQUIRED TO, IN ESSENCE, TAKE
CARE OF THEIR PERSONAL SPACE. IS
THAT RIGHT? YES. THAT IS NOT
CONSIDERED A WORK ASSIGNMENT
THAT IS JUST AND THE SAME THING
WITH A COMMON AREA THAT THEY
MAY, FOR EXAMPLE, THEY MAY USE.
IS THAT RIGHT FOR A COMMON AREA
THAT THEY MAY USE? WE ARE STILL
WORKING WITH THE, ADMINISTRATION
AND THE DEPARTMENT. WELL, WHEN I
SAY ADMINISTRATION, I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT ON
CLARIFYING THAT WE DO HAVE A
COMPANION BILL, AB 6 TO 8, THAT
WILL ADDRESS, WHERE THE
CONSTITUTION IS NOT CLEAR. AS
YOU KNOW, OUR CONSTITUTION IS
LIKE USUALLY THAT STATEMENTS AND
THEN WE PROVIDE GREATER
CLARIFICATION OR GUARDRAILS, SO
TO SPEAK, WITHIN THE COMPANION
BILL. SO WE ARE LOOKING TO
ENSURE THAT THAT IS MORE CLEAR
WITHIN THE COMPANION BILL. ALL
RIGHT, AND THE SAME THING, FOR
EXAMPLE, WITH RESPECT TO
CARRYING ONE'S TRAY FROM THE
MESS HALL TO WHEREVER ONE IS
REQUIRED TO CARRY IT FOR
PURPOSES OF JUST EFFICIENCY IN
THE IN THE IN THE DINING HALL,
THAT'S THAT'S NOT CONSIDERED A
WORK ASSIGNMENT. SO THERE'S WORK
ASSIGNMENT, SO RIGHT NOW IN OUR
BECAUSE OF THE INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE EXCEPTION AS IT
RELATES TO PUNISHMENT OF A
CRIME, WE HAVE IN OUR SECTION,
2700, WE HAVE LANGUAGE THAT SAYS
SHALL REQUIRE, INCARCERATED
PERSON OR PRISONER TO DO A
FAITHFUL. I THINK, DAYS LABORER
OR WORK, AND SO WE'RE CENTERED
AROUND THAT LANGUAGE. AND SO
CLEANING UP YOUR OWN PERSONAL
SPACE IS NOT CONSIDERED WORK
TODAY. YOU KNOW, CARRYING A TRAY
IS NOT CONSIDERED WORK. WHERE
YOU GET INTO WORK IS. AND IT'LL
BE DEFINED. WE'RE ASKING, THE
CDCR TO CREATE A VOLUNTARY WORK
PROGRAM. SO THERE WILL BE SOME
PUBLIC SCRUTINY TO THE
REGULATIONS ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
BUT WHAT WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT
IS, SOMETHING THAT IS TODAY
CLASSIFIED AS WORK, THAT NOW
BEING VOLUNTARY VERSUS SOMETHING
THAT TODAY IS NOT CLASSIFIED AS
WORK, JUST BEING IN THE, IN THE,
IN THE PRISON ITSELF WOULD NOT
BE TRADITIONALLY INCLUDED. BUT
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
CLARIFIED IN THE COMPANION BILL,
AS WELL AS IN THE VERY PUBLIC
PROCESS AS IT RELATES TO THE
REGULATIONS AND RULEMAKING OF
CDCR. SO THANK YOU. AND I DO
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT THAT WE,
AS A STATEMENT OF VALUES,
INCORPORATE THIS INTO OUR
CONSTITUTION, AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO FURTHER DEFINITION BEFORE
BEFORE IT COMES TO THE FLOOR, AS
WE'RE MAKING LEGISLATIVE HISTORY
AND DEFINING OUR LEGISLATIVE
INTENT RIGHT NOW, WE DON'T WANT
TO HAVE TO SPEND LOTS OF MONEY
AND TIME IN COURT SORT OF
PARSING THROUGH SOME OF THIS. SO
I WOULD BE GRATEFUL IF WE COULD
COME TO A DEFINITION AND
UNDERSTANDING SO THAT IT DOESN'T
CREATE UNNECESSARY LITIGATION.
NO. ABSOLUTELY AND THAT'S AND
THAT'S MY OWN DISPOSITION AS A
LEGISLATOR. I WANT TO LEGISLATE
AND NOT SEND THINGS TO THE
COURTS. AND SO YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT THAT WITHIN THE
COMPANION BILL AND WHEREVER ELSE
WE NEED TO, TO PROVIDE GREATER
CLARIFICATION. I THINK EVEN
AMONGST THE COALITION'S, SIDE,
THERE'S ANGST ABOUT SOME OF THE
WORDS BECAUSE THEY'RE NEW WORDS.
AND EVERY TIME WE PUT A NEW WORD
, IN WHETHER IT'S OUR
CONSTITUTION OR, OR LAW, CAN
CREATE, YOU KNOW, SOME AMBIGUITY
, AMBIGUITY IF IT HAS NOT BEEN
DEFINED. AND SO WHEREVER WE CAN,
WE WILL SEEK TO ABSOLUTELY DO
THAT. AND THAT'S WHY WE I FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT THE COMPANION BILL
THAT IS BASED ON THE PASSAGE OF
ACA EIGHT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT, JUST AS IMPORTANT AS
ACA EIGHT IS. WELL, THANK YOU.
AND I KNOW YOU'RE A PERSON OF
YOUR WORD. WE'VE WORKED TOGETHER
ON A NUMBER OF PIECES OF
LEGISLATION. SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. YES, THANK YOU SO MUCH,
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND
THEN THE COMMENTS, FROM MY
COLLEAGUE, SENATOR ALLEN. AND
I'D LIKE TO THANK, THE CLBC
MEMBERS WHO WERE ABLE TO BE
PRESENT TODAY. IT IS A BUSY
TIME, BUT THIS SHOWS JUST HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS, THIS IS, AS I
STATED IN THE BEGINNING, THIS IS
A PART OF OUR REPARATIONS
PRIORITY PACKAGE. THIS CAME OUT
OF THE TASK FORCE. THIS HAS BEEN
ATTEMPTED IN VARIOUS WAYS.
SENATOR BRADFORD HAS BEEN A
LEADER ON THE FLOOR ON THE
SENATE SIDE IN THE SPACE, OUR
COLLEAGUE WHO IS NOW
CONGRESSWOMAN KAMLAGER DOVE,
CARRIED AC THREE AND WE COULDN'T
GET IT ACROSS THE FINISH LINE.
AND WE AS A CAUCUS SAID THAT WE
WERE GOING TO DO BRING THIS BACK
NEXT YEAR. AND SO PEOPLE LIKED
ALLOWED ME, AS AUTHOR, INTROING
IT. BUT I DID IT BECAUSE I'M
CHAIR OF THE BLACK CAUCUS. AND
WE AS A CAUCUS DECIDED THAT THIS
WOULD BE A PRIORITY IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. SO I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES OF THE
OF THE BLACK CAUCUS AS JOINT
AUTHORS IN THIS ENDEAVOR, WE
BELIEVE IT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE LEGACY OF
SLAVERY AND FORCED LABOR RUNS
DEEP IN CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY
FROM FROM EXPLOITATION OF
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE AND SPANISH
MISSIONS TO BLACK SLAVES FORCED
TO MINE FOR GOLD. AND TODAY, AS
WAS NOTED, WE HAVE A HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A STEP IN
THE DIRECTION TOWARDS ENDING
THAT LEGACY. I SAID IN MY
OPENING REMARKS THAT THE US
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HAS A LIST
OF, INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE OR
FORCED LABOR OF MODERN FORMS OF
SLAVERY, BUT NONE OF THOSE WE
WOULD NOT CONSIDER CHILD
TRAFFICKING OR SEX TRAFFICKING.
STATE SANCTIONED. THE USE OF
CHILD PRISONERS, STATE
SANCTIONED BUT INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE IN PRISON RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE OF OUR CONSTITUTION IS
STATE SANCTIONED SLAVERY. AND SO
WITH THAT, I ASK YOU TO HAVE A
HISTORIC I VOTE OF ENDING
SLAVERY IN CALIFORNIA AND
VOTING. AND I THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, DO WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THIS? SENATOR
UMBERG, THANK YOU. SO THE
MEASURE HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR UMBERG. IT IS BE
ADOPTED, AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS BLAKE
SPEER, I LARKSPUR I ONE ALLEN
ALLEN I MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I
NEWMAN I NEWMAN I PORTANTINO
UMBERG I UMBERG I WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. IT IS 5150 AND WE
WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SO WE THANK YOU.
SO WE WILL LIFT THE CALL ON THE
REMAINING ITEMS. SO IF YOU ARE A
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE AND YOU
NEED TO COME DOWN HERE TO VOTE,
PLEASE MAKE YOUR WAY RIGHT AWAY.
WE WILL WAIT FOR THE ROOM TO
CLEAR. JUST FOR A SECOND.
OKAY, WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL ON THE ITEMS. SO LET'S GO
AHEAD AND DO THAT. LIFTING CALL
ON FILE ITEM TWO TO AB 1807.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
ONE. CHAIR VOTED AYE. VICE CHAIR
VOTED NO. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR.
Ã. UMBERG. UMBERG. I 661. IT'S
OUT THAT IS SIX ONE AND IT IS
OUT. LIFTING CALL ON FILE ITEM
THREE AB 544. MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ONE. CHAIR
VOTED I VICE CHAIR VOTED NO.
UMBERG UMBERG I SIX ONE. IT IS
OUT SIX ONE AND THAT IS OUT
LIFTING CALL ON FILE ITEM FOUR
AB 2050 MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
JUDICIARY. CURRENT VOTE IS THREE
ONE. CHAIR VOTED I VICE CHAIR
VOTED NO. ALLEN I ALLEN I
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I SIX ONE. IT'S OUT SIX
ONE IT'S OUT. LIFTING CALL ON
FILE ITEM FIVE AB 2839. MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO JUDICIARY.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO.
CHAIR VOTED AYE ONE ALLEN ALLEN
I MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I NEWMAN I
NEWMAN I60. AB 2839 IS SIX ZERO
AND IT IS OUT LIFTING CALL ON
FILE ITEM SIX AB 2355. MOTION IS
Dð PASS TO JUDICIARY. CURRENT
VOTE IS FIVE ZERO. CHAIR VOTED
AYE WHEN UMBERG UMBERG I SIX
ZERO. IT'S OUT AB 2355 IS SIX
ZERO AND IT IS OUT LIFTING CALL
ON FILE ITEM SEVEN AB 2642.
MOTION IS Dð PASS TO JUDICIARY.
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ONE. CHAIR
VOTED I. VICE CHAIR VOTED NO
UMBERG UMBERG I SIX AB 2642 IS
SIX ONE AND IT IS OUT LIFTING
CALL ON AB 2655. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO JUDICIARY. CURRENT VOTE
IS FOUR ONE. CHAIR VOTED AYE.
VICE CHAIR VOTED NØ PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I UMBERG UMBERG I61
AB 2655 IS SIX ONE AND IT IS OUT
LIFTING CALL ON FILE ITEM TEN AC
EIGHT EIGHT. MOTION IS BE
ADOPTED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO. CHAIR VOTED I ONE
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I SIX
CERVANTES ACA EIGHT IS SIX ZERO
AND IT IS OUT LIFTING CALL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ITEMS
INCLUDE AB 453 AND AB 3284. A
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. CHAIR
VOTED AYE. VICE CHAIR VOTED AYE.
ALAN I ALAN I MENGIBAR I
MENGIBAR I NEWMAN. NEWMAN I
SEVEN ZERO I'M SORRY. GO AHEAD.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS SEVEN
ZERO AND IT'S OUT SEVEN. DO YOU
HAVE MY VOTE RECORD ON FILE
NUMBER SEVEN. THAT'S AB 2642.
YES. YOU DO THE SAME THING WITH
2255. ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. OKAY.
THANK YOU. WE'RE DONE. OKAY
THANK YOU. THE COMMITTEE IS
OFFICIALLY ADJOURNED.